two
hello hello my friends one and all it is
april 15th
h3 podcast friday baby it's friday today
we have the best
lots of excitement electric
electricity is in the air
we're joined by
my good friends
idubbbz ian many people his his his uh
his birth name ian
yeah and anisa
you guys how long have you guys been
married
oh man
nine months nine months yeah but you all
guys been together for a minute now
because i yeah five years five years
damn boy let's go right now five and a
half five and a half yeah since 2016.
yeah yeah i remember meeting you the
first time i met you was the longest
time ago yeah we we've we've been with
you guys through like a huge
transformation it's been really cool
yeah well we're joined by by uh these
two lovely people and of course ela is
here yes history podcast forever and
ever
lots of applause
sometimes but there's definitely some
electricity in there i haven't been here
like three weeks i feel like so or two i
don't know i'm just gonna plug something
real fast um
how do what camera am i dragging to oh
the hdmi thing it doesn't work then
dead air dan
shout out to we've got tech problems uh
can you guys pull the mics a little bit
closer thank you i got a note from the
uh
sound tech okay
so anyway this shirt i'm wearing well
let's just do this this shirt i'm
wearing this one was real popular
loving it you better hurry over to
teddyfresh.com if you want to get one of
these before it's gone right ela and
you're still that's right thank you
yeah that's it that'll be fine
go ahead i don't know
i don't know which one
all righty
so how you guys doing i know you moved
to seattle mm-hmm yeah it's a beautiful
city i've heard i've never been there
yeah you should go
okay i do want to go actually
i don't get to go i mean we don't have
to do anything we have two kids now and
my life is over oh man they're great
though yeah you can travel with kids
not with a two-month-old not really yeah
yeah no you can but like
not just a question who are you doing it
for at that point because true i don't
know it's
fun it's going to be up against the
window like that
look you're in the air
the rand wrap him and just
check him in that's cool
yeah seattle though like i'm super happy
he was willing to move because like i'm
canadian he's from san diego so i feel
like it's like a compromise we're still
in the us but we're nor closer yeah so
you have an easier time are you still
traveling back and forth or is that
right now i'm not allowed i've been
stuck here well that's good right isn't
that what you guys wanted
but like my dad he's sick
and like i actually recently went to try
and plead that like i have an emergency
case and i should be allowed to travel
and uh the guy was like yeah alzheimer's
is not life-threatening
[ __ ] what and then i [ __ ] cried i
was like crying and then the guy started
crying because his like dad has
alzheimer's so we were both like it was
very good that's like when they go
dental is not a necessary medical need
right meanwhile your tooth is different
i'm [ __ ] dying of pain yeah
okay well there you have it the
alzheimer is not an urgent need yeah so
are you you're here in the process of
getting like a green card or something
change of status yeah a green card so
you can't leave no for what like
until or two years or something who
knows yeah it depends i mean covet
slowed it down but like they're super
like intentionally vague about like what
they'll like what the time frame is
they'll deliver things to you i have my
work card i can work now okay that's
good livable conditions yeah but can't
travel it says on the bottom my work
card not valid for travel well you can
leave but they won't let you back right
yeah they'll take it as like i don't
actually want to be here yeah yeah yeah
yeah so
oh look it's gabe you guys know who get
white clock game is
white club gabe he calls in every friday
to wish us a happy friday night and he's
always living his best life where are
you gabe
i'm in mexico
[ __ ] baby [ __ ]
where mexico are you
that's cabos cabo baby [ __ ]
at a resort baby damn damn
dude
gabe you're so you're the man dude i
wish i was in cava right now
you having white claws you kicking them
back or what
they don't have white clothes in mexico
but i'm having a ramen diet coke or
something
what you're having a rum and diet coke
yeah
okay
wow
what do you think
does it rain
hell no
it's always sunny in mexico i never see
it rains in mexico when i'm always there
[ __ ] baby [ __ ] no rain in mexico baby
[ __ ] yeah
does it rain in mexico
i don't think so [ __ ] though
damn that looks so nice right there
my fans here
watching here
pushing a friday video
[ __ ] yeah
man i'm so sad that they don't have
white claws in mexico what kind of crime
against humanity is that
i have no clue they never heard of it or
[ __ ] me [ __ ] it
i guess it's a america
a chicago thing it's kind of localized
well anyway uh uh what what was our new
saying uh suck on my balls [ __ ] what is
that my dick sick my dick
yeah
ow
horse [ __ ] energy
[ __ ] baby you guys so he's on tick tock
white card game oh you know what club
game yeah he's been calling in every
friday that's awesome for about a year
he's he's a friend of the show big time
he's a good guy we love conk energy
any plans to go to uh tijuana and see a
donkey show
ah
i don't know who okay
yeah you know you know well i don't know
if it's true or not but they say in
tijuana you can see a horse [ __ ]
somebody
oh yeah probably legal too
yeah i don't think they care too much
about
probably illegal
all right well stay out of trouble out
there you have fun don't don't get too
crazy okay you take it easy on those rum
and cokes those aren't white claws ramen
all right
[ __ ] me [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] baby
friday easter friday easter friday good
friday you gotta be good it's good
friday baby
good friday be nice to people
just be good that's why it's called good
friday baby
don't give an attitude to nobody it's
friday good friday that is [ __ ] babe
wow
i couldn't have said that any better
myself what a friday you go you go have
fun out there okay buddy you have a
great time nice seeing you
all right
yeah cheers
okay come on okay well
i'll keep that in mind i've got all day
to talk to them
we talk to gabe once a week yeah then we
gotta watch some of our youtubers get
beat up by 12 year olds
oh really yeah it's part of the training
yeah
literally
yeah
yeah all right so let's talk shop here
a b is fighting in your event
yep the uh flash creator clash creators
what is it creator creatorclash.com
ticket sales are going people are buying
they so you guys better get quick if you
want to get oh yeah the whole bottom
bowl is gone it was gone within five
minutes and whoa
pretty much
[Music]
now dr mike is you're fighting what a
goofball am i right you're gonna right i
don't know man are you so you say he's
just handsome you don't think he's a
good fighter because he made a video
saying he's been boxing for 10 years
yeah he's just handsome just and and he
he admitted
that uh the 10 years isn't 10 years of
serious boxing that's just fitness
boxing right
so
you know if you guys are making some
sports bets out there just keep that in
mind
is there odds out on this [ __ ] or not
yet or will there be i don't know what
odds look like for [ __ ] like this yeah
it's like based on what there's like no
completely wrong
yeah
but okay you're gonna did
dr mike's the kind of guy it was when
you're like no headshots
will leak some info
yeah info leak time info leak time dr
mike actually
didn't want to do a pro fight ian did
so that's
something
three minute rounds
and uh 10 ounce gloves 10 ounces small
yeah more pain also it goes on your
official record like everybody cares
about their pro record i'm sure dr mike
has got big plans in the how come you
wanted to do bro
what's that how come you wanted to do it
just because it was a different
experience it made it more intense and i
think a little bit more valuable to the
boxing crowd okay because all the
influencer boxing
i think most of the events have been
exhibition and they've been large gloves
headgear you know the whole nine yards
as far as safety and like
you know intensity goes so if we did the
pro level it would be like damn both
these guys are serious they're coming
out here doing like you know
a difficult level we would probably only
do four rounds or something like that so
it wouldn't be like mayweather type [ __ ]
but it would still be intense
but so it ended up because he didn't
want to do it you guys are doing amateur
we're doing actually exhibition um yeah
with 12-ounce gloves big clown gloves no
no it's still small they're about the
same yeah
i was just going to say the only
difference is like 10 ounce has to be
like pro it has to be 10 ounce if they
do 12 oz it can't be oh that's a small
difference yeah it's very small a b your
guy wanted to do uh hunder yeah
pro and i thought like everyone was
doing pro then when i found out it was
just idubbbz and dr mike i'm like [ __ ]
that
but then it's not even them huh but
they're not doing pro either anymore so
because dr mike's a [ __ ] he's a [ __ ]
no he seems like a nice guy everyone in
our event is nice
but dr mike did i'm just doing that for
the uh
did choose exhibition which is an
important fact if you want to place bets
go ahead so he you're saying he bitched
out
you're gonna mess that pretty face of
his up dude you think so because i was
watching an episode back we can cut to
that right where ethan says i'm gonna
get [ __ ] up by dr mike
do we remember that when that was okay
i'm honest i mean first of all like
you're you're
you're
you're like pretty tall and and i've
never seen you do like sports or
anything you seem like you've been
training hard
and but also dr mike is a [ __ ] he's
uh he looks good bro i don't know like
in that one maybe he's blowing smoke up
my ass when he was like this is just
some weird case of man love you just
love that music you want to [ __ ] but you
guys are the one coming here talk about
how handsome he is i never said [ __ ]
about dr mike i don't know yeah like i
think it's good editing you know you
also have garcia let me pull up that dr
mike boxing video he's saying he's the
best boxer you know youtube boxer but
dr mike also said that uh he was being
hyperbolic well you gotta understand is
he taller yes yeah two inches taller
two inches that [ __ ] how tall is
he six three i think oh god you're dead
bro
uh so if you look
he he posts good pictures i'll give him
credit you know he he
wants to look big in videos he wants to
look intense i don't put that same love
of effort sure sure you're not hyping
yourself up you look at my instagram
it's all in my gut oh my god i look like
et right now
really yeah
yeah same wow
that's tough
you have to eat a lot and then you also
have to be fit yes we have to gain
weight at least a b and i do um
and
i mean
by his perspective i think that's harder
to do than
losing the weight because uh man is it's
very difficult to yeah it's tough to
gain weight
i have a lot of trouble i hate trying to
gain weight i can relate to that i guess
it's a different battle it's yeah
everyone has their own we all have our
own battle yeah yeah you're an expert at
gaining weight it's true
i'm the same way i love eating it
actually pisses me off how like much he
doesn't like breakfast because i love
breakfast so i try to get them up and
eat and you like second breakfast i love
all if i could eat for breakfast a day
for breakfast it's annoying though it
sucks to be us because everybody's like
are you
such a weirdo shut up yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's tough no one relates to us
exactly everyone relates to you yeah
very relatable but i liked being
pregnant because i could eat a lot and
just have and have fun eating but now
i'm totally back to how i was before and
it's like sometimes just the thought of
eating makes me sick like i'm not
interested well i'll tell you what when
i was recently super sick i didn't eat
for like three days and i was like this
is awesome like i'm just not hungry and
i thought that was so nice i was like
wow this is what elo feels like all the
time is [ __ ]
[ __ ] that i'm always hungry and you
like don't care about food i always
think about food it's literally the only
thing i think thank you yeah so i get it
yeah but you're skinny legend i was
180 pounds at one point like wait before
i met him and everything i i'm like you
are how much 180 but i i'm i'm 1 30 now
but also the boxing that we do i mean
she boxes every session that i box yeah
did you want to fight i did what
happened i got hit in the head really
hard and sparring i got a concussion
and uh
and then i was like oh no we went to uh
the neurologist and he basically had to
beg me to stop
because he was like look like your head
is not good i've had a bunch of
concussions like my whole um yeah she
did sports growing up so like hockey
didn't ross and everything someone
popped in
uh
she
wait what she's uh someone saw i mean
who hit her so damn hard she's she's
been uh doing what what is she what what
does she do like kickboxing kickboxing
uh for like 20 years or something crazy
she's a real fighter the problem is it's
like when you first get into sparring
you either freeze or you like don't
understand how hard you're going it's
like really hard to know
um and i go hard apparently and i think
i just put her in a fight-or-flight
situation and she just like i like went
to throw a jab and like froze and she
just smoked me as hard as she was like
very hard so did you see that
no i was busy sparring oh
yeah it was scary
everybody
everybody was like oh even like she was
like oh [ __ ]
so like it was uh
it was a moment abey's been telling me
like uh
when he fights like people his size he
does pretty good but when he had to like
move up to fighting bigger guys it got
way way harder have you experienced that
in your practice
yeah um i think the strategy kind of
changes um
you know it's less it is less even it's
like just a different uh
factor you have to deal with it's going
to be the same if you go down in weight
it's like yeah you might be able to like
keep them at bay because they're smaller
than you
but they might be able to go twice as
long as you and you're just going to
potentially get [ __ ] up also fast yeah
and a lot faster the smaller you are
potentially the faster you're trying to
tell me that size is an advantage
it is an advantage yeah it is really
that's why they have the weight classes
yeah but it's not everything yeah i mean
especially when you're sparring because
you know it's not
it's uh you're not going at different
levels you know not no one's going all
out to
you know kill each other so it seems
like you and abe are both fighting
bigger guys
is is brett taller than abe i think he's
a little taller than me
he's a monster dude maybe he's gonna
[ __ ] him up um he's he's you do not
believe that i've been watching this
show
i don't know i i i'm just trying to be
real i'm i want to support av
that guy is scary looking but i abby's
been training really hard
it's going to be interesting
it's going to be exciting i'm i've been
so excited excited maybe yeah
interesting it's not good enough for you
it's not okay it's going to be hella
exciting we actually i was telling brett
this uh in the dms but we actually uh
are planning to have a b and brett's
fight near the end closer to the main
card because it's oh hell yeah
yeah they all they both been training
super hard they've been dedicated we've
been yeah we've been like keeping track
of like everyone's progress so we know
who started when they started mm-hmm
and abi and hundar were the first before
like oh everyone i was like
i wish
i kind of wish just for his sake he got
paired up with some
with some uh slacker that didn't care
that'd be awesome but now he got he got
paired up with this guy who's taking it
super serious no it's it's going to be a
really good fight for that reason though
it's going to be all the fights have
been like i i don't know what happens i
don't know if like people mind meld or
whatever but everyone i think michael
reeves and graham steffen they're like
at the same level of intensity as far as
i could tell um
uh everyone's like i don't think any of
the matches are like uneven at all
that's there's one that i'm
i am okay there is one that we're like i
don't know but we'll we'll see yeah dr
mike versus big nick or something
what the hell
it was big oh
[Laughter]
well i'm super excited to watch but
here's dr mike who's here's who i ian's
uh fighting dr mike through the wire
why you gotta do that he's like
so angry
this is ryan garcia yeah he's a real
he's a real mother yeah he's got a
really strong following in the boxing
world like one of the biggest
like well-known and he's his primary
trainer no no no no no oh wait they're
just doing a hype video yeah
[ __ ] they're collab dr mike lame l
he
he also uh did a i thought he was his
trainer uh amanda serrano which if you
don't know who she is she's a female
boxer who's like amazing she fights on
all the jake paul oh doctor mike did a
collab with them yeah what's dr mike got
all this all this poll well he's just
like big tv personality guy
he's got like agents and [ __ ] damn with
a face like that though i guess it's
easy to break into whatever you want see
no you're calling him hot you guys
started it
that's like his whole stick though he's
like i'm dr mike
i'm hot i'm hot as [ __ ] boy and i'm rich
and i'm a doctor yeah you're about to
get [ __ ] up by ian you're about to go
from a nine to a three
yeah true
[Music]
and again i didn't notice that there was
like a transition from the right
cut i didn't notice that either before
he's ryan garcia he really made carnage
he's really making it look like he's
training him or something
[Music]
oh
but i will say uh dr mike's coach is
good he's like a golden gloves winner oh
yeah he's legit that's good
how do what do you think about his coach
is he the real deal
i think
i think his coach seems legit um i mean
this is ian's coach by the way we didn't
energy what was your name michael
michael briggs uh bonafide boxing um and
what are your credentials michael uh
i've been to the legends i started
boxing when i was 12 years old i started
with like freestyle wrestling boxing
when i was 12. uh i trained from like 12
to 15 and started again at 17 and then
trained all the way through and then i
just left my old gym that i was at for
over 17 years
and went on my own about a month before
ian got a hold of me okay so yeah so i i
was an amateur boxer though um do you
think you could take a kickboxer do you
think you could take dr mike's coach oh
for sure for sure
yeah yeah i think i i'll take probably
any coach on the show for sure you think
that that i would like to watch can we
have a uh yeah the coaches fight out at
the end he's no offense to him but yeah
i just would take any of them for sure
describes him as a spider getting hit
with raid when he starts going off oh
[ __ ] yeah unpredictable but then you die
that means like he just dies though
afterwards
yeah
exactly that's actually pretty much what
happens and then sacrifice myself every
time even a b you really like your coach
could he [ __ ] up uh
it would be interesting they have a very
different style because i've trained
with michael a few times too when they
visit uh it'd be interesting
very interesting
his coach was pro for a while and i
wasn't so his coach would for sure be
the favorite but um i'll put myself
against anybody for sure any time
and then i'll put ian against any
youtube boxer any time oh sure do you
think he do you think ian could take
jake paul uh so we got a journey so if
if uh oh [ __ ] that's not good when he
says journey he wants to if he wants to
he could do it if he wants to he could
do it because actually do you think jake
paul is actually a good boxer uh i think
he's dedicated a lot to i do think he's
a good boxer yeah i think um especially
because originally he was like i like
what ian said originally he was an
influencer boxer and now he's a boxer
that's also an influence here right so
yeah he seems to have dedicated a lot of
time to it for sure yeah that's
interesting and he's got um
he i think he just has good perspectives
on like fighter pay and i think he's got
like as much as he calls himself like a
bad guy or whatever i think he does have
a um
a good
um a good heart for what he wants to do
for fighters
yeah yeah
so most people don't most people
manipulate fighters just like probably
this industry as well where people just
want to take advantage and get as much
as they can out of the people i think a
lot of uh promoters and fighters are
like that our fight coaches are like
that and i think he he is a little
different to be honest i i see it
it's very similar to like the porn
industry for women
uh the way that fighters are treated
it's interesting yeah it's very
exploitive they get them young
and they don't tell them all the
consequences and they don't pay them
properly and they don't represent them
properly that's
that's really interesting uh comparison
yeah and there's no unions or anyone
helping them no one's protecting them at
all yeah what's interesting about the
porn industry lately is how women have
been or well anyone in the porn industry
can go
like there's so many people becoming
like multi-millionaires by going and
making oiling fans and doing their own
thing
but the box boxers can't do that we
we've actually joked about it a few
times making like and only fans for
fighters only boxers yeah where like you
can pick your favorite fighters and like
give them monthly money to like support
them on their training journey and like
kind of like a patreon and it sort of
pivots them into the world they kind of
want to be in and they're encouraged to
go in which is the influence around
um you see a lot of these uh mma guys
and stuff patty the baddie this is one
guy who's like trying kind of making a
name for himself um
and if they could you know if their fans
can show them support in that way it
would probably be you know
a much better path than what they're
trapped in now it seems so is it your
belief that this influencer boxing thing
isn't just a fad and you think this is
like a real growing uh totally uh the
sport needs to like evolve over time
right like
like we've sort of seen that like boxing
pay-per-view numbers have has been going
down
um
except for these influencer boxing
matches which are like bringing a lot
surprisingly
successful yeah yeah yeah so i don't
think it's going away i just think it's
a matter of like who's going to
sort of merge the two worlds like
effectively and i think jake paul is
doing a good job of
merging those two worlds i think he's
focusing a lot more on the serious
aspect of fighting because he doesn't
really have very many influencers on his
boxing cards these days
it's uh i think in the last one they had
sports guys on there yeah but it was
mainly fighters and that's a good thing
if he wants you know to you know
show support and love to the fight i
will say
um
him picking up serrano who like female
fighter she's a crazy record bunch of
knockouts which for women is really hard
to do because they only give women two
minute rounds it's very hard to knock
somebody out in two minutes she's
knocked out a bunch of women
and she still wasn't getting the
attention that she should so he's
actually had her as like the undercard
of like a lot of his fights and love is
another guy that uh he picked up on his
team who is not getting the recognition
that he should be and uh it's been cool
to see i mean it's great yeah so very uh
fighter centric jake you're is it is
that how it works where he gets to pick
who's who's fighting underneath him he
has like a lot of influence i'm sure
that he's got some
daddies above him that are like making
bigger decisions but it seems like he's
down for everything he's been advocating
for fighter pay and all the all these
sorts yeah i think dana white is
genuinely actually scared probably with
what's going on for sure
well he's done a definitely a good job
of agitating him that's for sure yeah so
okay
well here let's get back to this monster
that's about to get his face pummeled in
by this [ __ ] insane boxer ian
golly
i've been boxing for 10 years ever since
my mom passed away and it's been such a
he he's fighting with the spirit of his
dead mom too i don't have any yeah your
mom's alive right yeah i see
i'm just saying bro you ain't got you
don't got what he's got
incredible outlet for me watching all
this youtubers start boxing has
reignited my passion for the sport he
looks vascular dude
but being cut like okay not having a lot
of fat on your body or water retention
it's
it's a bit of an illusion sometimes
especially on video i feel that i feel
that
show you how hard i've been training
what do you think coach how's he look
uh uh ian looks better on pads and ian
hasn't been boxing he didn't look better
on pads after like six months this video
is from october 18. here's the thing is
these are all like edited highlighted
clips yeah and you're talking somebody
was with him all day long
and these were the clips that they came
up with to make him look as good as
possible
and um he looks okay but it it also
doesn't look like um
he's a real boxer it just doesn't look
like he's it's it's from from it looks
like he's an athlete trying to force
himself trying to box being versus being
an actual fluid box i think he's a [ __ ]
actually
uh
i mean i think he's a soft individual oh
he's soft and comfortable
he is soft huh yeah well i mean yeah you
can find harder you could you can have
muscles but be soft his mom died though
um yeah exactly yeah i know yeah what
well
when uh dr mike offered to fight ian we
actually showed that video to our coach
before taking it and said what do you
think and michael was like oh yeah
that's fine [ __ ] that guy yeah like he
was so confident so like we've been by
the way i'm goofing doctor mike but it's
a good he's gracious to take you up
because you got you had other people you
were gonna fight who kept dropping out
obviously ricegum giant [ __ ] [ __ ]
boy yeah we're gonna he wanted three
million dollars yeah
that's super interesting yeah alistair
mcbroom will pay him that charity event
yeah no problem crazy
that's the only reason he contacted us
by the way is because austin put that in
his head that he could get yeah yeah
well bryce is still waiting for his
money yeah oh my gosh stupid
and then you're gonna fight oh without
that guy blueface oh yeah we're gonna
have blueface fight uh matt watson
matt watsons are like uh who's matt
watson or a skinny guy on the car super
mega yeah super mega matt watson he's
great he's uh
you weren't gonna fight blue face was
there someone before dr mike oh there
was a time it was either there was a
time it was either blue face because at
the time we were still trying to get
rice gum for him and blueface was in
talks and it was either going to fight
him but matt watson really wanted to
fight blueface oh yeah then you're going
to fight jeff whitake i was like what
the [ __ ] that guy is like taylor holder
his eye going to pop out of his head if
you well yeah he told us it was fine he
was like oh yeah i'm fine and then we
got a phone call like maybe a couple
weeks later and he's like yeah i can't
do it i was i'm like thankful he's not
because i don't i just yeah i don't want
him to go through anything it is
dangerous yeah
i mean he look he's look he's a he'd
probably be a good fighter but i just
don't yeah not the time i mean he seems
super into it um i wouldn't be surprised
if jeff whittak is in on uh influencer
boxing match in the future in the future
yeah just as long as he's his healing is
yeah well yeah yeah but i like jeff yeah
he's a sweet guy
yeah oh yeah he was super nice on all
the calls we had with him yeah
all right let's watch dr mike a little
bit longer i'm joined this
some guys have it all and so then you go
you know [ __ ] that guy i'm gonna be a
hater uh yeah dr mike yeah yeah totally
it's like yeah yeah there's no problem
hating on the doctor my philosophy is
yeah if he's got all this cool [ __ ]
going on he's rich and ultimately
a good boxer so you think just [ __ ]
work that's where you're wrong the guys
that have it all have it all
like tom brady you think so yeah tom
brady except he kisses his kids on the
list he does make out with his kids
do you think jake paul has it all
no no no okay what about logan paul
no i don't think they have it all
okay i mean you need to have like a good
image like outlet no like i mean like
he's smart he's handsome he's successful
i mean jake and logan they have baggage
like their dad like lives in a van and
[ __ ] their fans
i'm just saying like dude i don't know
anything about dr mike can we talk about
that the the messages with you and oh
that'd be great yeah yeah yeah great
paul yeah oh he wants to get in on it
well i had like greg paul was one of the
guys that i wanted to fight initially
because i thought that would be kind of
epic to be honest
with that yeah to fight greg paul and
then like
even if i just want to do that one fight
if i could take out greg paul so good
yeah i could
you know foot in
i [ __ ] your dad up yeah the trash dog
writes himself
but i when i dm'd him
it was it was that sort of weird macho
[ __ ] where it's kind of like i'm going
to out crazy you where it's like i won't
do a boxing match but i'll do an mma
bare knuckles
yeah he wanted to get in there biting
and [ __ ] yeah oh yeah bare knuckle cage
match he really said you're too scared
to get in with in the cage with me and
then he was saying he was going to beat
up him and rice gum at the same time
um
uh but yeah it just
he's he wasn't serious about it okay it
just fell through i i think i dm'd him
when i was getting really desperate like
he's 58 dan just informed me
i think he would kill him in an mma
fight 58 i don't know old man old man
strength something special yeah but at
58 i think you're just older my my dad
i'm telling you he's 59 alzheimer's
written doesn't eat and he still can
beat the [ __ ] out of my like older
brother it's a weird kind of like you're
excellent the wires cross in a weird way
where
it's like
all your muscle potential all the lack
of testosterone for the last 20 years
comes surging yeah
yeah i swear there's no limiters yeah
like on the because like there's
something to be said for that
[Music]
killed him
gp is out
all right back to back to this [ __ ]
goofy [ __ ]
[Music]
that's weak slow blame
i think it's time to see ryan garcia
ten years in the game with mike more
ready than ever so that's his coach the
golden glove winner yeah
okay he's got a real is that an
expensive guy to pay do you think
i'm sure in new york dr mike hired an
expensive coach yeah yeah i'm sure that
yeah
like yeah dr mike smart he's probably
not gonna just hire somebody that's that
bad but at the same time uh if he got
with this guy before he was planning on
fighting and this guy's more of like a
fitness boxing coach in new york
you could be a golden gloves winner but
still
not really
understand like coaching fighters well
especially because i've worked with
amateurs i work with professionals i've
worked with a lot of people so uh um
i've been able to take people that
weren't professionals and turn them into
professionals i've been able to take
people that like worked at microsoft and
google which was near our old location
and allow them to be good enough to work
with professionals uh i i could see that
guy
allowing people to be able to work with
professionals i don't think he could
actually take professionals and make
them better i also um
i don't want to talk too much go ahead
no that sounds great
but either way i just feel like um i
feel like dr mike would hire a good
coach but i feel like he hired him
before he had a fight planned and you
think he's a fitness coach
he came at me specifically to fight yeah
so i wasn't training ian for fitness i
was training ian to fight somebody um
although our first opponent he would
have won pretty easily with without much
training right but then when we had our
other opponents i was like that's why i
accepted dr michael i really liked the
match because i figured uh if we're
gonna take on somebody that's like
bigger more athletic people will view
this as a much bigger challenge yeah if
you [ __ ] up mike that'll be good though
yes it will look really good for us
there's i don't feel like ian's a
favorite in the matchup well like if you
fought ricegum nobody would be impressed
no
yeah it would be like you saw when
fouseytube fought and
yeah he got like he's he had to get like
facial reconstruction
right it would be more like that that
was awesome super impressive like just
soaking punches he's like homer simpson
and when he fought mike
they showed me that actually they were
like look at this how many punches this
guy took dude the announcer is like put
up your hands man for god's sake
put up your hands i love that video yeah
yeah that's not what we're going to look
like
we met with a plastic surgeon in l.a to
talk to him about like
you know giving disney facial
reconstruction for everyone yeah are you
serious yeah okay
yeah for nose jobs like he was like yeah
i'll give you guys i'll give him you
guys you guys are getting a groupon on
those jobs
wow yeah you guys really care about your
fighters man props yeah just use code
items and just build it back but a
little nicer than a little nicer
i think it's time to see ryan garcia
plus okay so you expect that i can do
something yeah about doing this but i
heard it's crazy making it right okay
around six four yeah
six minutes 44 seconds okay good call
good call guys is that when he's doing
the speed yep
is this impressive or what just a show
i mean he's just sitting there taking
punches which is a big deal yeah
yeah in a lot of these videos it's just
a little bit more for the youtube
audience rather than boxing audience
yeah
right and he's wearing a huge pad take
that off if you want to press me right
right yeah but also this it's like
that's so pointless uh
it's disappointing
that's that's not that's not good
training just to take no
it's purely for youtube it's like a
thing that garcia does where he has
people like a bodysuit challenge but
it's oops yeah it's a body shot
challenge thing that he does but at the
same time like for youtube views it's
great but no fighter would ever train
that way that's not that's not like a
legitimate reminder training method
whatsoever there's a tick tock that uh
tony jeffries who's like a really
well-known uh boxing youtuber he was an
olympic boxer he responded to this tick
tock where it was just like this guy and
he's like oh i'm training my fighters
and these fighters were just standing
there with their hands down
like just with their heads out and this
guy was walking up to each other oh yeah
yeah i saw that the head i saw that that
didn't seem like good training
i i've gone my gym's a really like
serious gym like anyone who knows wild
card box like it has a reputation i've
been going every day almost for like
seven or six months i've never seen that
before ever taking three shots to the
face
soaking hits to that that's yeah that
doesn't seem like that's what you and
your like middle schooler buddies do
when you have a sleepover right all
right let's get tough
don't talk about this
don't tell mom
ten punches are you even impressed by
that coach yeah what's the context yeah
yeah
not pressed not impressed i'll say ian
will take at least 12 of those
oh yeah i'm just doing it but no i just
it's once again that's not an actual
like thing uh thing to do for training
it's just purely for views got it um
yeah i'd rather actually see him like
uh
try to do like some sort of flow drill
with him where he's got to do offense or
defense and then see if he could take a
body shot like that during some sort of
actual drill
let alone like i wouldn't i wouldn't
have him spar ryan ryan would murder him
but even just like a light drill would
be way more
uh i would see much more from that than
clips like that give you nothing they
don't you know what anything i have
noticed with a lot of these like
influencer boxers is like none of them
want to film their footwork or head
movement at all
at all
we have videos of your head i just said
i just sent a video of anisa now this
would scare the [ __ ] out of me if i want
to see that i'm going to watch hers next
but is that what you wanted me to see
because i'm not the time stamp you sent
now
yeah that was it well after this his
coach this guy says he could take on any
youtube boxer yeah
what's it feel like immediately after
you know that they have those horse
races and the horse gets angry and kicks
someone right in the face that's what i
just got in the shower nobody watched
horse races weirdo yeah it was a weird
reference
it's like some boat club yacht seriously
what's your background bro you know when
you're playing polo
on horseback and
your privilege is showing dr mike
maybe there's boxing in my future i
don't know i'm gonna leave that up to
you uh i'm gonna stay here right now
he beats any youtuber
oh no ryan
do you think he beats logan paul him and
jake on the same night i appreciate it
yeah not an honor not an honest comment
obviously
all right dr mike i'm teaming in right
now i think ian's got this in the back i
think you can get dr mike on the podcast
you'd be dr mike and i wouldn't talk to
that guy that's my enemy i wouldn't have
him on the show
i feel like after hearing all you guys
uh points of view and watching this i
i'm starting to see that it's a little
bit yeah it's kind of just for show
how much can
yeah like he's obviously into working
out and looking good but i think he's
more into looking good the actual
impressive stuff in boxing that other
boxers look at and go like oh that's
impressive most people would look at and
not know what they're seeing right or
why exactly yeah
so this is a nissa training apparently
this is this is uh
yeah i'm very proud of that actually
again okay
so you can't fight anyone you're not
allowed to fight uh no unless i want
to set a heavy bag
so with this footage you can see a lot
more contacts and you can kind of see a
little bit better how it would translate
to a fight also like shifting head work
um and like i move after punching which
is like
huge like you can even see michael in
that clip when i like
do
move my head like roll after the punch
he like gets super excited about it
because like that's hard to
get somebody to do especially when
you're really new like
this is insane footwork well hold on
they aren't familiar with boxing thank
you almost every day my coach slaps the
[ __ ] out of me and the side of my head
like that because i'm not moving or i'm
not moving like she is like that is yo
where's the video of your feet work and
all that [ __ ] ab oh they don't let us
record at all in my gym what yeah my
coach my coach will record me just to
make fun of me and he won't stop wait
but
we gotta hype you out we want to see
what you got
he won't let you do it for the promo
he's not an influencer boxer he's yeah
wow
yeah yeah legit yeah wow you're on a
wild card you're you're not messing
around yeah right that's the gym well
where's the videos of your
feet working a lot uh i think we'll get
we'll probably have some of that not out
yet no i don't want to yeah you're
keeping it close to the vest totally
yeah but if i look like that
yeah just demand you know why are you
keeping it close to the vest it's like a
month away
oh yeah just for promotion and stuff
where there's gonna be a lot of footage
going out i'm okay about it okay yeah
i'm not actually keeping close so let's
say you destroy dr mike
[ __ ] him up dude he goes rush the
hospital brain damage can't practice
anymore oh i definitely remember
oh really yeah that was terrible if i
give someone why it means you have
potential that's right
you're a good fighter that's so evil oh
man well it's not your fault he stepped
in the ring
he stepped in the ring he knew what the
stakes were yeah
so he steps in the ring he dies okay
jesus
just saying ian's really good for the
record we're being very safe in this
event all fighters well the reason why
we wanted to get all the fighters going
as early as possible is because like you
need to learn how to like move your head
and defend you you don't want a fussy
tube situation well even worse than that
this last showstar one was like
what not to do which one it's uh it was
an event with alex wassabi and deji
oh okay i didn't i actually didn't watch
that one uh not many people did
okay so what was that it was oh and
vitaly
vitaly basically as far as i know his
opponents are defenseless uh women
walking their dogs legit
i couldn't believe that they put him on
why is he not in jail why has he not
been deported i think they're waiting
too for trial really i think that's what
i was reading last update was he got
acquitted on some of your charges yeah
acquitted
not acquitted but the charges were
dropped for
yes drop down that's what we read huh
interesting yeah for another podcast i
saw a video on that
what that's all about i know sometimes
people can be paid to
not right
you can pay someone off on a criminal
charge to drop well to drop it yeah not
to stop pressing charges yeah just stop
yeah that is possible that's what
happened i'm not
[Music]
and surprisingly yeah that's what he's
like there was a headbutt in that fight
but it wasn't vitali that did that oh
there was a headbutt i remember no
headbutts
yeah yeah um super dangerous um it was
the uk versus america yeah poorly wrong
uh so we're just we just want to make
sure that people can defend themselves
that they're not getting desperate in
the ring that they know the rules you
can't headbutt you can't throw a kick
you guys take it very seriously yeah
yeah it seems like you guys are doing
yeah very professional uh respectful
yeah we're putting everything we have
into this right yeah we don't do
youtube's on pause we do this you know
six days a week and uh yeah yeah our
money's tied up in it uh now you guys
this is a charity event so you're not
making any or i mean all the profits are
being going to charity yeah yes we're
paying our fighters just to cover their
like training costs training costs and
you know flights any yeah costs
associated with
sort of putting their you know life life
on hold and even even still a lot of
these guys do make a lot of money when
they're not fighting so
we can't make up for that but uh just
you know
what's your angle you guys are putting
your i know you you had a pro you had a
profitable business on only fans
you obviously are a youtuber you guys
put all that on hold yeah you are
training putting on this event
is there like a payday in the future you
guys are working towards no not really i
think we always want to have if we keep
doing this uh type of event and we kind
of want it to be like a super bowl like
every year you want to do it again yeah
yeah i see um
if it works out then we can do that um
and there could always be a charity
aspect to it um you know i but i think
the
the main goal is just to get the people
paid who are involved in making it
happen rather than like making
exorbitant amounts of money so your goal
is to build an institution of sorts this
creator clash where you can have fun
there's a champion every year it's a
party interesting it's like a stoked way
more exciting vidcon or like like i want
it to be like influencers can like care
about this and fans can care about this
and like just go watch it and have like
a build up like maybe parties before and
like stuff like that because we've gone
to like the last jake paul event and it
was crazy the amount of influencers that
were there decided to see it they
weren't all my you know cup of tea sure
but it was exciting everyone wanted to
be there it was fun
and i think if we can harness some of
that but have it be even more exciting
because
all of our fighters are mystery fights
you don't know how it's going to go and
then you have this you know charity
element it's just like a win all around
so in the future maybe let there'll be
more profits potentially for you guys
potentially but we're not looking at
that really would you still continue to
fight like is that something you want to
do if i have to yes to like make it
successful um like if people are you
know wanting that but it's not a
personal passion
i i am passionate about boxing it's just
that there's a lot of unknowns right now
especially with running the event and
everything i just don't know because it
consumes this has been a like a
nightmare to
train and also run i mean like we just
flew in from we did like basically two
red eyes
one to florida to like walk the venue
and like talk to because we have the
live producers and then we have the
broadcasters they have questions for us
and then we have to like okay things or
whatever figure out budget figure out
safety for the influencers that are
going everything and then we had a red
eye here so we could do like podcasts
and like meet up with the fighters and
check in on them and and then we have
like calls with the publicist that we're
like on the way here talking to p like
we've never been this we're trying to be
super legit about it and as a result i
will say
the i'm glad that we're on this podcast
because i think
the big catalyst for us i mean i don't
think we've ever said this to you guys
but like when we went to your house and
we saw the frenemies podcast that you'd
set up you actually said something to us
that i feel like
kind of got our brain going of like oh
[ __ ] we need to start moving it was like
you were like yeah i spent money on this
set because i knew it was going to make
money and like i knew it was going to
make it work i'm not worried about it we
talked about hiring people and stuff
with you guys and like it was a huge
like
aha moment for us where we were like we
need to like
do something like the idea of us like
doing something like this is oh yeah
this is way bigger than we even thought
like we we had gone to seattle moved to
seattle
uh like june of last year and we were
like all right like let's get an office
and we got an office
and we started making things out of that
um but almost immediately we were
consumed with like uh the boxing thing
uh the whole rice gum drama and trying
to set that up so
since then it's just been you know
we we sort of bit off more than we can
chew yeah it's falling into place now
falling gracefully and then just like
hoping everything worked i mean
everything's been going great but
also it gets terrifying at times and we
have to try and fix that
remedy that it's a lot for two people
yeah you're gonna we gotta hire some
people yeah yeah i'm assuming yeah why
are you you're not gonna you don't want
to keep boxing in i thought that was the
whole legacy
i'm invested in you as a fighter you're
saying that sarcastic no i'm not
no i'm not too no i think he's great i
don't know why you're saying that i i
don't think he get like i watched a lot
of work like i'm not like i don't want
to [ __ ] promise [ __ ] if like if this
is like if if the event sucks or well
sure if the event bombs then but it's
not you already said you broke or if i
just do a bad job i don't know how i do
in competition so we got to see how you
do out there yeah yeah
ian's also the king where's the
confidence are they going to rip his
head off he's going to do well you're
going to do well where's the confidence
yeah yeah no i mean i have i was going
to that's why i'm spending so much time
on this thing almost a full year
it's just uh yeah it has been almost i
think people need to like
i mean that's sort of the problem i have
with a lot of this influencer boxing is
it's like it almost feels like you're
i want it to be more real because i
think a lot of people don't really
conceptualize how serious the influencer
boxing is or a boxing period not
influencer boxing but i think
influencers end up finding out how
serious it is when they get into the
ring and a lot of our fighters were
super confident before
getting started and
it's been
[ __ ] like tough for them huge like
calls not you know give up and not say
oh this isn't was there a lot of people
that were trying to back out once they
started training there were plenty of
people yeah yeah was there people there
were people that backed out right there
was people that disappeared most of that
is for injury but i have a feeling like
just in general like if you are gonna
back out from an event like boxing your
best excuse is an injury yeah yeah yeah
hey mentally this is [ __ ] me up or
i'm too scared or anything like that i
know abs he's uh i'm admitted but he
fantasizes about dropping out all the
time
yeah it's hard work we get to see his
experience and like it's such a hard
it's hard commitment and
you have to put time into it and it's
physically hard and mentally there's so
much it's crazy i actually i tuned in to
your twitter space abs twitter space uh
for a second yesterday because we had
some time and i heard something that
made me really sad because ian feels the
exact same way where it's like he was
saying i don't know sometimes i spar
and i feel like i'm you know amazing i'm
doing really great and then i'll come
back and i'll spar again and i'll lose
really bad i'll be like man did i get
lucky like what is that but like
ian it's the exact same thing with him
like i mean he's sparring against guys
sometimes that have had 14 years
experience
um and he'll you know get flustered and
not know what the hell is going on and
he'll have those exact feelings yeah i
was gonna say uh even when when she told
me that last night i said yeah welcome
to fighting so they're just being honest
like it's not like every day is a good
day and it's not like you just it
progressively like goes upward and oh i
know how to box so every day is easier
it's literally a roller coaster so
you'll have like great days and the
great days like you almost feel high
because you have endorphins you have
dopamine like it's so good but the bad
days are so stressful yeah and it's
literally like you just dropped right
off a freaking cliff so you'll have
these days where you're so high and
everything feels so good and then in
that same week or it might even it might
even last longer than a week it might
even be an entire month where you feel
like [ __ ] and you're just getting beat
up every day and uh and it's like you
might be a pro fighter for years and
you'll have really good camps you'll
have bad camps and so when i heard him
when i when she said that he said that i
was like yeah welcome to fighting it's
not like every day gets progressively
easier you'll have
days you feel good you'll have days you
feel bad you'll have entire camps that
you feel bad you'll have entire years
that you feel bad
and then other times you'll feel great
you'll feel great for three years and
you'll win all these fights and then all
of a sudden you'll just hit freaking um
that that downward cliff and that's why
like he's so honest because he's like
well i don't know how long i want to do
this or if i want to do this if
everything just went better every day
it'd be like of course we want to do
this forever until i die but some days
are really good and we're like yes
you're getting it and then the very that
maybe later that same week it's like uh
oh are you getting it or are we getting
it or am i failing you as a coach or are
you feeling as a fighter yeah and then
three days later it's like we got it
again
so it's it's crazy it's in their their
relationship throughout this whole thing
has been super interesting to watch uh
there's this one we're gonna do a
documentary but ian ended up sparring
with one of the youtubers
and uh had a very emotional super
emotional free ian why what happened
you get your ass beat
i mean i look back on the footage and it
wasn't particularly bad at all but in
the moment in a new environment and like
a new level of intensity
everything feels there it feels like a
lot worse than it is you went in there
expecting to do better yeah
you got rattled i think sometimes when
we think hey we're better we could just
show up but
when we're better and we just show up it
doesn't mean we're better you still have
to put the work in so i think
where we thought we were better we're
saving that for the documentary
so one of these fighters rattled you
yeah yeah yeah of course but
everyone gets rattled he wanted nano he
did win in the end he you won the fight
well at the end of the sparring session
like
he could have easily finished it by the
end of the sparring session i was
telling ian to take it easy on the other
guy ian started going a bit
yeah you know in any learning strategy
like everyone's different so at first
you have to kind of learn how the other
fighter is you could be getting [ __ ]
up half the time realize this strategy
and then it completely turns over by the
end of the match so why did it rattle
you so much what happened well i have
never been in competitive sports at all
so i am completely new to like the
dynamic of like
people are like watching you in a live
setting uh you have people telling you
what to do shouting uh their
your opponent's coach shouting at them
to do things
it's like
it's
if you haven't been in the situation
it's like impossible to describe the
feeling but it's intense and it's super
emotional super emotional especially
when you're not prepared for it which
you know that's sort of what leads you
to this point it's just like it just
[ __ ] you up it's like very uh
exhausting also going back to what i
said about sparring you either freeze or
you like go way harder than you think
you're going when you first start
this guy is he was going way harder than
he even was aware and was like head
hunting like was like trying to like if
you watch the punches like and he wasn't
it wasn't intentional it's just like he
was
swinging so
for ian it was like oh [ __ ] um so what
what happened you're fighting this guy
he gets some good punches off
and then you feel like you're losing and
you're just shocked by that yeah well no
i mean like anissa's saying this stuff
my coach is saying stop just got
like a mental thing than anything else
it wasn't hurt yeah like you just felt
like i had i would be like
this [ __ ] sucks but like i wasn't
bleeding it was that you were like
confused or overwhelmed or something
yeah we were shocked we were shocked at
first yeah because we were like oh this
is going to be fairly easy and then it
wasn't fairly easy so i think at first
we were shocked you're like i'm not as
prepared as i thought i was i well so
that those thoughts came into his head
but he didn't realize how much he knows
and how much he can use sometimes he'll
uh and this is common for everyone
you're almost near the person in front
of you so if they move really well
you'll move really well if they move
poorly you'll move poorly i compared to
like football teams that for for because
a lot of people don't understand
fighting but they understand football
better and it's a time where that like
that is a really good football play team
but will play down to the level of the
team they're playing against so it might
be the best football team in the league
they play the shittiest team and they
play like they play like [ __ ] but then
it's very similar where you could be a
you could be an okay fighter but if
you're one with a good fighter and you
can move like they move you can perform
really well all of a sudden now you're
in there with somebody that doesn't
really know what to do or how to throw
and you're not used to
uh when we're when we're trying to be
technical you're trying to learn things
and then sometimes it turns into a fight
and there's a there's a boxing coach
that says uh like sometimes you gotta
throw that boxing [ __ ] out the window
and just fight and and that's very true
like there's not many other sports
where it's like oh they're throwing the
technique out the window but it's
working really well
and sometimes with boxing if you're used
to people throwing straight punches and
somebody throws a shitty punch it's
harder to block the defense is made for
good punches so when somebody has off
timing they have bad punches things are
different and then you have to adjust to
it and so we were shocked for a little
bit but then we like i said we did
adjust but
it was a new environment
at the end it was i mean the thing is is
like ian's cardio is
really like good
um so like this person that he was
fighting their cardio was not good so
like just like truthfully like they're
on the ropes and they're you could tell
they were like super overwhelmed and ian
just like yeah i think like the point i
kind of want to make is like
the
side of boxing that we've have been
seeing is
i think this side that you're kind of
drilling down on which is like so did
you [ __ ] him up or did he [ __ ] you up
what happened
and we kind of want to like elucidate
this bigger picture of boxing where it's
like it's not as simple as like this guy
wins this guy loses it's like a whole
journey and we're trying to like
document that yeah through the process
because it's not like you know abe is
like putting in a [ __ ] ton of work uh
you know since november
and like
you know if he does go in the ring
whatever
ends up happening it's like
like i want people to recognize sort of
the uh amount of time and dedication
that is involved in that rather than
just looking at like whatever the judges
or you know whatever ends up getting
scored and being like all right that's
you know that's that
and just sort of close the book on it
because it's a lot more complicated than
that
yeah every fight is a story basically
it's cool it's i mean once you start
like learning about boxing when you
watch boxing it changes everything i
remember our first time watching
influencer boxing and going back and
watching it now and being like oh holy
[ __ ] yeah once you understand the sport
you know it's like it seems like uh a
lot of the fight fans are just like a
little bit um
a casual fight fans they just don't
appreciate in the same way
what do you guys think of these
influencer fights like let's go back
what what's your take on like logan paul
versus mayweather
um
it's cool it's a weird kind of money
grab thing but yeah like i don't know
what do you think about that fight coach
um
i hated it as a fight but um i i respect
those guys for what they're doing like
he said it's um that was a money grab i
don't think anyone really considered it
an actual fight i think it was just a
money grab i um i i personally
uh
am a
huge fan of mayweather as a boxer um and
what he's done and what he's done to
build his brand there was too many
boxers in the past
that ended up with nothing
and not to say that he might still not
end up with nothing with who knows what
his spending i i pray that he's doing
well and his spending habits aren't bad
but but they seem to be um
but
as so many boxers they end up at the end
of their career with nothing and they
end up having to work at a
at some place to just show their face to
get an appearance fee and it's still not
worth it and i think with mayweather
what he did with building his brand and
building something bigger than boxing
that that was that to me is why i will
always respect him um and then same with
like logan like with where they've come
from i think him and jake with where
they've come from to be able to to even
have a match versus mayweather it's like
it if
for to use a term you guys use it to
meme you know it was i never really took
it as a fight that wasn't like that it
is
yeah and then and then they they turn
the meme into a huge cash grab so that's
how i look at that
what did you did you expect mayweather
to beat him oh my god i expected him to
do so much better yeah
but logan was so much bigger so was it
like was it i think it was one a size
thing i also think um
i
logan didn't really so the other thing
about fighting is the other guy has to
kind of commit to fighting if you don't
really commit you kind of throw a couple
punches and back off so mayweather threw
i think like an average of less than 12
punches around which if you're in a
three-minute fight that's four punches
in a minute
you could throw four punches in a minute
in a fight and be okay like that's not a
high output that's like so i don't know
if mayweather was just trying to not not
actually fight because he didn't want to
be embarrassed or uh like embarrassed at
the fact that if he tried hard he didn't
knock this guy out so if i say hey i
barely tried and i didn't knock him out
then it's not as embarrassing so who
knows um but like i said from a fight
perspective it was not a fight at all it
was a total meme uh but i do think that
like for logan or even jake to be doing
what they're doing it's it's it's so
that part's impressive what did you
think about like jake paul versus ben
askren
so uh i i actually so i told everyone
that would listen so because i i used to
train with a lot of mma fighters uh
demetrius johnson mighty mouse was my ex
teammate for like 15 years so i trained
with a lot of really really high level
mma fighters he was ufc champion for a
long time for people that don't but
either way i i trained with a lot of
high-level fighters and when that fight
was announced people were asking me
what's gonna happen and i was telling
them jake's gonna knock ben out and they
said what are you talking about ben
never had a style in mixed martial arts
that like he he almost relied on bad
striking to invite people to hit him the
worse of a striker you are the more
inviting it is to want to hit you and
the easier it is to take people down if
they commit to once again if you're
playing defense it's hard to commit to
too much because the guy doesn't commit
to too much but if i can get somebody to
over commit to everything because i'm
like suck at striking then it worked out
well for his game so when people were
like oh what do you think's going to
happen i was like i really think jake's
going to knock him out i had friends
that bet made a lot of money on it
because i was like jake's gonna knock
him out plus ben had come off hip
surgery he was truthfully really fat
like i i i respect that
i respect ben as an athlete and as a as
a wrestler i think he's one of the best
wrestling coaches in the nation probably
i think he's an amazing athlete in
wrestling but he is not a boxer
he should have never been in that boxing
ring uh my friends made a lot of money
because they listened to me but uh yeah
so that that fight went exactly how i
thought it would of a guy that actually
has been taking boxing serious um i i
think there's a lot of people
here's the thing is jake could beat a
lot of boxers but i don't think anyone
he's beat has had one amateur fight
so like not professional fights but i'm
saying i don't think anybody be had had
one amateur fight which means that he's
not fighting anybody that takes boxing
seriously yeah for sure
were you surprised by him not like
knocking
tyr uh jake
that was a little more surprising i
thought woodley would have done a little
bit better in the second fight because i
thought he would have cared less it
actually looked like they both cared
more because the fight was so freaking
boring until the knockout and that's the
thing i think people like forgot how
boring the fight was because the
knockout was good but yeah i was shocked
by the knockout i was also shocked how
poorly he performed i thought that he
would have come out harder um and and
made it a better fight because i thought
with the first one being as lackluster
as it was he would want revenge and
actually bring it and then if he would
have brought it and got knocked out in
two rounds i think people would have at
least been like oh he brought it versus
only talking about the knockout but the
fight was so boring before all you
remember is the knockout that's true
here's a suggestion to you ian uh
elderly clash if you want to get greg
paul
around
is that chuck liddell i think chuck
liddell would murder him but uh yeah
yeah yeah we're not we're not
i i really like that victory pose though
but you can count on him have something
cool like that and necromancer yeah
i love his shirt old man fight gear
no hype no bull just old school just old
he's mug blooded for sure yeah yeah do
you guys like uh a mug
mug yeah brew beer
i like root beer sure yeah mug root beer
sure yeah i like mug are you saying he
drinks mug root beer is that a diss ian
ian let's say something ian's tick tock
algorithm like his for you page is like
solely
mug blooded american memes mug
it's uh and he sings it all the time it
goes like uh how does it go you're mug
blooded you hear my freedom
veins are filled with ruby
and there's always like uh like bulldogs
like in the videos big bad ass bulldogs
um
drinking root beer that's nothing
interesting i haven't been on that side
i've been in weird parts of dick dog but
not that one you gotta get on that side
he really likes it so let me ask you
let's look at the other matches we got
harley versus ego raptor that's kind of
a weird matchup
harley's massive harley is massive is he
go raptor big
uh ego raptor's pretty big i mean he's
over 200 pounds is he tall i've never
met him one i think one because harley's
like six four or something insane i mean
harley like i don't know i caught him
exaggerating his height
oh
we have one of those in drama
yeah we know something now harley's
harley's a very good guy um i just was
uh it was funny he was honest about it
because he was in his stream he was like
yeah guys i'm six six and i was like
hell no
he's not he's like oh it's a glamour
inch glamorous
we measured his ass and he's six two no
i said six three for the record i think
he said six four bro
he's actually six four and he's massive
like zach looks small compared to him a
glamorous you like that i like it
glamorous i got a glimmer obviously my
boy eric uh is going to crush whoever
this guy i don't know who dj welsh is
he's an animator but i was like
crazy ass we have an extra water thank
you
um eric is my boy but he's a smoker and
a drinker and that doesn't worry about
him yeah
i don't think he's stopped either oh how
could he that's that's that's his whole
that's who he is
but i like his vibe
i mean he's strong i feel like he's
strong he's got big calves
yeah big cat he's got good proportions
on him i was worried because there's a
lot of fighters who are uh heavyweights
200 plus pounds and they got it all
right here oh yeah and that's like no
he's he's built well yeah yeah what
about the guy that is fighting uh dj i
don't know much about him i talked with
him briefly but he's one of uh james
odwin's outs uh buddies yeah they're
both animators
um but uh dj has a little bit of like
fighting experience oh [ __ ]
eleven years ago yeah eleven years hey
hey okay all right i'm rooting for eric
obviously you know like he has very
little time to prepare so uh it's so
funny the the littlest details i'm just
saying you could be like yeah i played
you know i know i wrestled for you know
a summer
it's better than nothing
muscle mass
that [ __ ] matters yeah
it might like you
it might like ian said it might actually
not matter at all but it depends on
whatever
it depends on what you did like if he
fought as an amateur then okay but like
he said if he like trained for a summer
at a yeah that's the fitness gym yeah it
might not be let me ask you this can
eric smoke salvia before the fight
florida is very liberal with that stuff
they are yeah just as long as you're not
gay you're cool
um
yeah the south florida oh florida don't
say gay right yeah
yeah we just got taken off in florida
but uh
the um
my brain just blanked what were you
talking about so yeah yeah yeah
no drug tests or anything i don't think
they were oh [ __ ] do you think any of
these fighters would take steroids
no no but i mean dr mike right he's got
the he could prescribe whatever he wants
yeah dr mike's writing prescriptions for
testosterone hormones let's start that
rumor
if he wins that's what happened
no drug test you heard that a.b i know a
guy yeah you know l.a hit me up but yeah
yeah erica this is honda have been great
yes can i talk about this
dude
[Music]
it looks like you just woke up bro
we're in a discord together right they
sent they sent a sample photo of like an
edited picture yeah like we're going to
do something like this so i thought they
were going to like edit out the
background and everything and then the
day of i'm like freaking out like i'm am
i the only [ __ ] in my living room
with my shirt off
in fairness i thought we were going to
edit them we did also think that we
didn't do the graphics yo look at this
the first few photos i saw everyone had
a shirt on to him like what the [ __ ] is
going on yeah ian doesn't have a shirt
on so you're a king with that i'm just
saying
i like it
it looks massive i know he's pushing his
arms against his body to make him look
bigger he's also still he's a crossfit
king
so crossfit i mean that's endurance no
it's a lot of well oh you think oh we're
across it's a lot of hypertrophy right
it's a lot of like glamour muscle which
you're not flexible
and you're going to need a lot more
oxygen in the ring you know like it's
just harder to like keep the endurance
going but i will say he's lost like he's
he's gotten with the program he's lean
he's leaning on doubt
it's gonna be a good fight yeah he's a
good guy he's actually i like hyundai i
love him
he's super sweet
he speaks nicely of ab2 which i like
he's definitely got major like dad
energy like out of all the fights that's
bad that energy is bad
that's good for him yeah i'm saying
that's good for a hyundai that dad
energy there's a lot there is he a dad
no he just he's responsible he's a
responsible guy yeah if he was a dad i'd
say you're [ __ ] toast
the chance that everybody's making a
tough guy face amy looks like he's
pouting yeah
yeah is that your tough guy face amy
i listen i can't make a tough guy's face
when you have big ass eyes you like
don't look intimidating like it's just
you look constipated quite frankly yes
you just you have the you have like i
don't know the lebanese lips and the big
big eyes and the yeah it's hard to look
tough i get that
sorry no it's not good are you gonna
change up your look at all for the fight
what you think i'm not intimidated yeah
what does that mean what does that mean
like you know you could do different
shave off your eyebrows
i'm just letting it grow out no i'm
leaving it cut it out as it grows out
we're making them teddy fresh gloves and
robe right nice yeah custom [ __ ] i
didn't i don't think i've said this on
air but after my first time sparring i
was just ready to quit like i was
[ __ ] done
ian like talked to me about it prepped
me for it which helped um but it
happened to be that night is when ela
messaged me and like offered oh you know
she wants teddy first to make you some
stuff and i was like oh that's the
coolest [ __ ] thing ever so
it actually motivated me oh interesting
i appreciate it and then when i heard
that now i feel responsible yeah when
you die
when you die we'll know it was our fault
because i was like oh
i thought you were all in already i did
not mean to push you into it i know i
didn't indicate that i was out at all
but yo
journey it was funny he uh he was
wearing uh muay thai shorts and there's
a a youtube influencer like boxing dude
he's gonna commentate for us who does
like breakdowns of like fighters like
influencers and so he was trying to find
any clip that looked like someone maybe
fought so he found a clip of hundar in
like muay thai shorts
but honda just wears those for like
because they look like a dog he's never
said yeah but the commentary he was like
oh [ __ ] he got the shorts yeah
the best part of that video is then he's
like let's see abey and he like i have
like 10 videos on my channel he didn't
look at the podcast look at my personal
channel on my instagram oh he he looks
like a nice guy
he looks like a nice guy what's going on
here who are the who are the ladies yeah
this is yodeling hayley yodeling she
yodel no i don't know maybe oh she
doesn't actually yodel amy it kind of
looks like she does yodel wait what's
she like a dick doctor she's a tick
talker yeah she's a dancer i know her
wait how are you going to be yodeling
haley and you don't yoda
i have a problem with that
um like what was the kid the western kid
who used to he's a
walmart kid walmart jason yodeling mason
yeah totally mason
so is she uh
practicing uh yeah she's she's boxing
she's getting uh professional lessons
and uh she's 19.
19 years old and then and then this is
just
minx is my
my big pick
yeah for sure she's a twitch streamer
uh irish 25 and uh irish yeah
okay
she's awesome
yeah she's super funny um
both of them were super down when we
asked them to do it there was like zero
hesitation yeah a lot of uh a lot of
minx fans in the chat i'm sorry oh
just the means yeah
i'm very excited to see minks too she
gonna destroy this yodeling lady
you just always pick a side with
the audience oh yeah yeah yeah i just
feel nervous for everybody yeah
of course it's going to be yeah if i'm
nervous
you know it's tough like we're we're
going to see where you have an open
workout uh which we should probably
advertise that tomorrow we have an open
workout that's going to be on s fan tv's
twitch channel he's going to live stream
it um what does that mean
they're going to do like pad work we're
going to do like a bit of sparring we're
going to try and wait i have an update
yodeling hayley is actually the favor to
win she's awesome i've heard her yodel
it's incredible
dan just told me she's a fan a huge fan
of the show so we love yoga haley
[Music]
these hands are going to do the yodeling
but yeah the open workout is pad work
there's going to be some sparring but
we're going to try and keep going to a
boxing gym and just doing what you are
going to be sparring with who just a
bunch of youtubers it's just you no no
it's it's are you going neighborhood
probably half our card a b is going yeah
i'm going huh oh you are yeah yeah so
we're gonna hit pads and just have a
good time i'm just gonna be on twitch
yeah okay interesting interviews and
we'll go around talk to people
commentate on it it's gonna be
a lot of fun interesting great love that
uh moving on we have uh these this match
up
just trying to keep it open could be you
could be me in case yeah ethan you want
to get in there yeah i want to fight
keemstar
no oh no your mom now my mom yeah true
that's a good that's a valid excuse
people think because she was in the
heart i really even imagine anybody
getting hurt it's like yeah i think
becoming a mom is even
exaggerating all those feelings yeah i'm
super worried for a b i'm worried for
you and now i'm worried for the yodeling
haley it's like
no yoda is she gonna crush
she's a dancer so i think her footwork
will be oh yeah
yeah yeah a lot of these are really
important elements i think a lot of
people don't really realize how what
what sports and backgrounds like
influence boxing and how quickly you
learn
um so yeah
um but people think ela because she was
in the army is like a fighter she was i
can't emphasize no he's literally a
secretary he's not a violent person
she's not a fighter but that's it yeah i
was gonna say your vibe is not violent
like i don't think i've ever heard
me
no you're not a fighter you're
definitely not a fighter i saw some
comments that they wanted us to fight
really comments so i understand that
we're gonna fight ela
that's a shame i would like to see you
fight but i guess if it's a medical
thing then you know i would have loved
to i think what really got me with the
neurologist was he he was like yeah
alzheimer's is a very real thing that
you know is influenced by that yeah yeah
i'm married i mean i watched my like my
mom you know takes care of my dad and i
definitely don't want to do that yeah
it'd be a pretty shitty gift yeah the
worst not worth it
but getting punched in the head can like
advance it oh no way yeah
a lot of people in sports deal with that
for sure alzheimer's depression ms these
are all like very does anyone ever get
happy from getting punched in the head
too hard
i guess that wouldn't be like recorded
to the same level the thing with uh they
found with it's
the nfl soccer and boxing are the worst
for
long-term head injuries because soccer
yeah small
hits to the head impact from balls you
think yeah
oh wow fastball yeah it's the head i
could see that i mean they slam hard
enough you hit the same area and the
speed uh those three sports are the
highest for like long-term
like ms alzheimer's depression
suicide there was actually a nfl player
who when he committed suicide he
actually shot himself in the stomach so
they could look at his brain because a
lot of like long-term brain injury you
can't look at it until
they're dead yeah so he actually did
that on purpose and wrote a note like
studying my brain and they looked at it
and they were like holy [ __ ] yeah i
remember hearing about that his brain
was all [ __ ] up yeah yeah the nfl's
football is a crazy-ass sport because
they're just now discovering how
it's just devastating for their health
when i grew up the playing the sports
that i played it was like you got a
concussion or you you you know your head
shut off for a second and your coach was
like are you dizzy no okay go back out
and sometimes you'd get like multiple
like i've i've had at least one major
concussion uh in my past that i went to
the hospital for and four minors
and from what uh lacrosse and hockey i
played men's lacrosse and those balls
like they're getting shot at you like 95
miles per hour wow um so like i i've
been knocked out by a shot you know
before but like back then coaches would
look at you and be like we gotta finish
the game but like it's that's horrible
like we're finding out that that is like
the worst thing you can do so we had
another uh chills
also canadian played hockey growing up
uh he had to drop out because he has
post-concussive syndrome as well yeah
chillz was one of our fighters
i don't know who chose burger king
footloo
burger king foot lettuce i mean i know i
know what burger i know burgers but do
you know burger king footlong no i don't
know
do you know like the number 50 like
number 15
burger king foot lettuce nope is that
ringing a bell no it doesn't yeah i
think your crew might yeah you know top
10 worst times of something happens
burger king foot left if i saw that in
my living room i would stamp it out i
don't know here we go zack you you've
got a talent with impressions you got to
keep working on those
last thing you'd want in your birthday
i've never thought of yours
but as it turns out that might be what
you get
a 4channer uploaded a photo anonymously
to the site showcasing his feed in a
plastic bin of lettuce with the
statement
this is the lettuce you eat at burger
king admittedly he had shoes on but
that's even worse
but that's even wow he's a super nice
guy
he accepted the boxing match straight
away he was super down to do it and he
also makes uh very good music oh ian we
played his music at a wedding uh ian
requested from the dj and he was
breaking it down on the dance floor
yep so here we've got i don't know who
ryan mcgee is i know who alex ernst is
ryan mcgee is the other half of super
mega so
big guy good fight here i think it's
gonna be a great fight interesting yeah
uh yeah both of them have been preparing
well
this guy looks pretty tough who's this
oh versus dad dad's a monster athlete
that's everybody ever he is talk to is
like i don't want to fight dad no bro i
was we he he didn't he called into the
show
he was in the chat he's in the chat
right now actually oh he's in the chat
yeah he's a fan i love him
but he's a monster athlete i mean he's
dancing credentials are insane
you've seen him shirtless too like he is
like
yeah what what's the history of matt
watson so matt is a little bit skinnier
uh so he's got a bulk up look at that
kill him
that's what master face
yeah
just go crazy
like any time anyone's like oh abby's
gonna die because how big brett is i'm
like i feel for matt watson because dad
like has like merch like with matt's
tombstone on it and everything that
might kill matt
he's really nice though and i appreciate
him defending uh me and my wife against
keemstar so shout out to dad oh yeah oh
dad was dad was writing for you yeah
yeah keemstar was like doing his whole i
never said his wife so which i just sent
a picture and then
dad was like okay come on like are you
being serious right now why would you
just send you know wait so what happened
with dad
sorry i wasn't listening
i was just looking at dad keemstar was
doing a twitter room and he was doing
the usual keem slide saying i never made
fun of abu's wife i just sent pictures
of witches yeah and then nathan was in
there dead and he was like okay like you
know what you're doing you know what
you're doing that's good mm-hmm good guy
smart guy yeah why didn't he didn't want
to put his real name huh he said just
put dad well this is this is who's
fighting this is who's fighting his dad
he's fighting
barnett is not fighting he's fighting as
dad i like that
that's good he's always committed to the
character oh yeah i love it i i can't
wait for people who are unfamiliar to
watch he's going to put on a great
stream and they'll be like dad like what
he's got
oh
you might be a nice guy but you're
[ __ ] dead bro matt has more reach
than dad matt's much taller
dad's fast and he's young this is like
basically the youngest guy on the car
versus the oldest guy
41 i think yeah wow but he's
we were surprised crazy credentials yeah
but he's not an actual
i don't think he has kids oh he's got
kids but that's no no he doesn't have he
doesn't oh no
kids not a real dad i'd like to know
which of these fighters have kids you
know
uh
i don't look at that list wait does
honda have kids i don't think so no
scroll no one i don't think i don't
think anybody has kids uh all
[ __ ] uh no you're not childless you
have kids
childless there's too much at risk if
you have can we have dad call in to get
is dad a member can you call in he is a
member let's try to get him to bring in
we'll say hi to dad
dad reach out to me on discord um
another interesting fact about our card
as well is that we have a lot of
older people on our car yeah
not on purpose not on purpose it's just
i guess all-inclusive yeah
uh
and not one fatty damn yeah
so hateful
oh and that's another thing is we have
more heavyweights than a lot of other
like there's some big big like tall and
heavy yeah i know odd one out is an
animator i don't know who i did a thing
i didn't think it's awesome
makes the funniest videos he's
australian and uh he just makes the most
bizarre videos just kind of some of them
are like social experiments some of them
are like weird inventions he makes tries
to solve problems he made a shark proof
wetsuit recently yeah
really did he put it to the test he did
yeah and then he also made like a big
animatronic uh
clamping shark yeah i'm gonna say i'm
impressed these people are brave to come
out there and fight like a lot of these
people i wouldn't expect
like the odds one out i mean i don't i
just know he's an animator and yeah
you're like animate or stop crazy you
know y'all coming in like michael reeves
is out here fighting what the hell
we were sean
those two specifically they said that if
they were
privately separately from us if they
were to fight the only person they would
fight is each other so when we called
them and asked them about the mashup
matchup they were like yeah like that's
literally that's what we said
this is such a cool matchup for the
exact same height exact same way that's
crazy it's a it's going to be they're
both shorter dudes they're like what
five five or something five five dude
that's awesome right uh we were
originally i think we got michael first
and we were trying to find someone you
know his size and is that what he's been
doing instead of making videos of course
yeah training yeah um
and also he doesn't make that many you
know well that's what i was saying
because
yeah um yeah but we were going to have
captain sparkles yes
michael reeves
uh since sparkles is bigger isn't he uh
i think maybe a little bit bigger but
captain sparkle's pretty sure oh he is
okay and yeah um but the the problem was
is captain spark was absolutely jacked
yeah like way ahead of fitness
he felt like it was irresponsible which
is fair
yeah yeah jordan himself said that he
was like yeah i wouldn't feel
comfortable getting in the ring with
these guys
that's good of him yeah no it's super
helpful he's he he was
very helpful in the
is the event gonna be with all these
fights i think about a few hours three
three hours
probably it depends right like if it's
hard to know with the run of show a
fight might end
in 10 seconds in the first round right
you know yeah so
we're prepared for however long it ends
up being our commentators are also
[ __ ] yeah nice nice names
critical and xqc
i'm actually not familiar with s fan but
i know he's big write love i mean love's
all into twitch yeah s fans big oh yeah
and we obviously got chills involved
since he couldn't fight he wanted him to
be involved in some ways
um but yeah i love those dudes well this
is very exciting yeah i have a
dad on discord if you want me to yeah
bring him in yeah let's bring in one
second
let's talk to dad get him on the line
here
we've got dad calling wait let's switch
sides
yeah why do they switch side here that
depends on who you clicked on yeah who
your player
let me get some intel on matt watson
before i talk he makes good music too
yeah you can see his diss track his diss
track to dad in there oh he made a dead
diss track yeah oh [ __ ] yeah they've
been going hard with their beef the
first video uh yeah down here oh this is
the one you know now if i if i play a
clip from the show are you gonna sue me
or is that kosher the show or from the
event yeah um
highlights are allowed to go out from
what we know like you can't like
obviously like you're not going to sue
me uh but that's like moment house
partner that controls okay well let them
know that i don't [ __ ] around
i'm already being sued once all right we
have um we have dad on the line i
believe in the house no are you there
i'll be watching some clips from this
dad
dad
everybody's asking for their dad right
now dad that's theodore
daddy dad do i hear him or is that
keemstar somebody
oh hi i'm here oh i oh oh my god
yeah what is what a sultry voice i'm
here sorry i'm talking on a e-phone and
it's giving me some errors what's an
e-phone
oh it's made by company the company i
work for here in town usa
what's happening
an e-phone like a mobile phone like a
smartphone right from town that's a
cellular device
okay sorry but i'm all set now
okay nathan um
first of all nice to uh meet you this is
dad is this dad or nathan you're
speaking to dad this is dad but uh i
have all nathan's memories so i can
answer anything you want okay dad now
who's your children who are you the dad
of uh so my daughter's head blew up last
year you can see it on my youtube so
she's no longer with us her name was
daughter but now i have a new son named
qb and he's developing well thank you
for asking
okay
now this guy
i'm a huge fan of the show i watch all
the time and this is a legit honor to be
on and a b
all the way
yeah maybe all the way
yeah i don't know if you heard the last
time you were on i was talking i was
singing your praises because i've been
watching your videos for a while i've
known about you for a while back at your
your dancing videos and i love it i
always loved it i was one of those
videos back in the day that i would show
my co-workers and friends and stuff you
know so this is thank you i saw that
episode where you were talking and i was
losing my mind so that's so cool very
much so this guy this guy this guy matt
watson's been talking mad [ __ ] what are
you gonna do to him
um so i don't know if people heard this
is actually so it was a friendly
competition up until
uh i got like a week ago when i did the
super mega podcast like legit no joke
it's not cool anymore matt is a lousy
person and it's for real now he insulted
nathan in his scientific haircut and uh
i'm not down with that so
i don't really have great things to say
about matt watson
what's the worst thing you guys i think
what is that what's the worst thing
you'll say about mount watson here today
okay uh he's a he's a drug addict and
i'm gonna snap him out of it when i
knock him he does kind of look like a
drug addict in that photo
[Laughter]
i will say he there is only room for one
pop star on youtube and that's dad dad
is the number one pop star and matt and
all his lousy songs will be erased from
the internet after this fight
okay well
hang with me a sec there's a one-minute
diss track here he made about you i'm
going to watch it okay that's crazy and
then i want to get your call of course
if you watch the course of mine you'll
realize how much more effort i put into
it and i use 2012 youtube energy to
destroy him
oh so you made a diss track too so let's
watch who made the first diss track him
matt
matt okay so let's watch his diss track
and then we can watch yours okay
okay all right stand by
[Music]
when we do our little square dance with
the cubs in the big ring nathan yeah
then bones be aching
dirty old man couldn't even figure out
your age with the
carpet oh [ __ ] it's the nursing home
a little bit of a limp biscuit uh thing
there right totally are you intimidated
by the limp biscuit back backing voice
there dad and am i intimidated by his
cliche on the nose generic rap that
everyone this is like something phase
clan would do this is just so
that's a good point
maybe you should change his name to faze
watson eh
yeah
i agree yeah i mean blaze watson because
he's always in a cloud of drug smoke
what kind of drugs do you think he's
using
no he says the whole thing is audience
myths the supermarket audience knows he
does crack and i was at the super
megaplex and i saw these crack pipes and
it was very uncomfortable
i don't know what that's going on over
there but they're not ready for fighting
ryan i think ryan will win
his fights ryan is definitely they have
different trainers and he is putting
more effort into it than matt and matt
even mentioned to idubbbz on their
podcast to idubbbz and anissa that he's
not putting effort into it is that true
i don't remember that
he he said that he's eating a lot of
gums
he said nathan's putting more effort
into this thing
so so you're saying here today on on our
show that he smokes crack
i don't know i don't know anything about
drugs legitimately i don't i don't even
know how to do marijuana but
i saw things that were very suspicious
in their house do you know what a crack
looks like their video was taken down
recently for drug use is that true
yeah that's fact but it was like a joe
crack use or like i mean if it got taken
down
yeah i don't know the jokes here make
sure things aren't a joke yeah boxing is
legit you're right you can and and and
crack it could be i don't know if you
smoke some crack before it could be a
performance enhancement maybe it doesn't
feel pain at all and i don't know
bath salts could be a problem yeah
although there are no drug testing so
that's legit are you worried about that
since like there's no drug testing are
you afraid he might juice
i even if he did steroids what he his
100 pounds will give what gain what even
if he doubles to 200 he'll just match me
that's true okay all right let's
continue let's continue this lint
biscuit uh
rendition here
but i can't lie you got good muscles and
i'll give you that oh
yeah i refuse to lose
anime
is that true do you have anime tats dad
all right dad's a bit of a weeb i'll
admit it
that guy
i got some pretty rare 90s anime tattoos
on my human skin so
i think it will i have hajimeno ipo the
greatest boxing anime in the world i
have one punch man tattooed on my body
to fuel me
oh yeah yeah i think it can't be you
kind of look like one punch man if you
thank you thank you
for halloween two years ago so thank you
i'm a big fan there's nothing wrong with
that
i love one punch man as well it's like
the greatest anime ever made and that is
my motivation mass motivation is doing
drugs he just wants more drug money more
crack money pretty much pretty much okay
okay nathan i could see that you're
visibly shaking i'm the big bad wolf
with the g i'm a brand new porsche
trader and i heard that back in the day
your first job is the guy who digs the
graves so if you think i'm the one that
you wanna box he's a shovel nathan pick
a spot
it's possible to interpret that the
shovel's for his grave
oh that's true pick a spot yeah if
you're the gravedigger yeah and he's
giving you a shovel oh
that's true
he was an actual gravedigger in
massachusetts before he moved to los
angeles and so he's making a jab at a
public service that nathan was offering
for people who are mourning
burying their loved ones that's like
that's hard to do and he's making fun of
that
yeah that's not good right we don't like
that well so here's your matt watson
everyone cancel matt
hey here's your response
so
also my song features his best friend
ryan from supermega and alexa updog his
two best friends decided to come on
because they know how bad that is
wow that he also doesn't really have
real friends
no he's like a loser to me he needs to
change his life
i think this is good anissa and ian
brought him on because they know this is
what matt needs to this is an
intervention
this whole event is disguised it's just
an intervention
all right so i'm going to put on your
diss track now and let's see let's do a
comparison here it's a bit long so if
you wanted to skip to like now
it's one minute 20 seconds
i think what he's trying to say is it's
boring in the beginning
one minute 20 seconds
yeah there's a lot of step
okay i just want you to hear the hook
and what a real test i'll watch it i
watch the whole thing
i got a minute
okay i got one minute for you
as long as you get to the course that's
what matters
okay
also that playstation one it's pretty
rare at the portable playstation one
with the battery pack that's a little
flex for you
that
that does look i've never seen one of
those in my life
i think i think you know who keith
apocary is i might have stolen that from
keith abacary the classic gaming wiz
all
he's right impaired and insulting his
choice to show his pride his manga
tattoos his anime wives he should love
who he wants let him live his life matt
is so mean dare i say vile i i i can't
take it dad's about to cry
if you'd like to see the full music
video in response oh you're on the wrong
channel
oh no
wait the teaser that's a teaser
how many how many channels do you have
man there's just two there's dad and
nathan i'm dad you're talking to me i'm
dad bought in okay so you made a trailer
oh this is five minutes yeah that this
you're asking a lot sorry sorry i hope
that that's why i'm saying skip to 115.
all right so i'll skip to 115.
you're going to hear the same thing all
over again that's okay so so
115. let's do one minute i'll give you a
little grace i forgot when nathan
because i knocked him out that's why
nathan's not fighting in this because i
dubs originally talked to nathan but
then dad stepped in because i'm the real
fighter so
okay it's a bit confusing i'm aware
no i think i got it
songs laughing all night the super mega
boys are heroes of mine but it can't be
true it can't be real matt what did you
do now what did i hear you attacked
nathan for losing his hair a genetic
defect he's fallen
insulting his choice to show his pride
his manga tattoos his anime wives he
should love who he wants let him live
his life matt is so mean
dare i say vile i i i can't take it
dad's about to
cry dad cry
[Applause]
dude you're jacked bro what the hell
that's what i'm saying
he's a dancer he's got like [ __ ] abs
again i gotta go back for that
you're really flexing and collecting
that
he made fun of nathan for his age so i
was just saying and dad bought for his
age was like okay well yeah i'll use my
old man abs then since you don't ask why
do you have abs bro
dad was programmed i'm programmed to be
the best youtuber and in doing so you
have to be a dancer you should be a
singer you have to be a vlogger you
should do it all right that's what dad
does and i dance a lot my when i did a
10 hour non-stop dance stream i was
telling anissa earlier about training
i dan i can dance for 10 hours non-stop
and i do not stop moving
time
boxing is a different thing even after
that this is still the hardest thing
i've ever done
you're gonna [ __ ] him up
that's the plan
and elderly packs will power my fist
through your drug addicted chest where
i'll find your
father's
heart
[Music]
so obviously yeah i mean this it is
quite long you're right so yeah yeah
yeah i have to say shout out to home
randy goff who produces the music from
these my albums home is a legend i'm
sure a lot of people know of him just
going to mention his name we got merch
already going on for the boxing event
matt watson tombstone merch is selling
better than any of my march right now
i that right
it's all it's 90 super mega fans
that's awesome are you worried you might
have people returning the merch after uh
he beats you
all sales are final
oh come on how dare you what is this dad
channel
it's it's it's uh the best thing i can
say people like the comparison i
disagree with it but for those who don't
know the closest you could have saved
for my channel is it's like the father
of poppy
but it's very different that i make i'm
a pop star i don't know if you want that
title that girl definitely no it's very
very different but people don't know
just assume that so i just kind of say i
know i'm kidding
okay let's let's get a little taste of
dad i'm actually just curious dad i'd
say watch diana search diane on my
channel that's the best way to kind of
intro
it's uh diane featuring yellow that's
one of my most
diane dad if you search that you'll find
it feels dead feels yeah yeah that's my
channel name
okay hello there's two of them
you want you want dad dad feels hi oh
wait there's two of them what the [ __ ]
what's going on with probably going
right there yeah okay no
not for the second one wait that was the
first one you clicked the second one
this is the you haven't been on youtube
in ages no i clicked this one right now
that's the night
i'm talking like in order
chronologically technologically
[Laughter]
wait a minute wait the one you clicked
ethan is three years ago the other one
is one year ago you're actually right
well it's it's sorting it by
okay do the one with the lady in the
still
[Music]
life gives dad reason
to
[Music]
but dad does wonder why
[Music]
is
[Music]
i don't know what's happening but i like
the dancing
[Music]
i feel like
some of these dance moves are like
pretty unique to
nathan slash dad yeah
like
have you been like uh
like contacted by fortnite or epic games
oh well i can't legally talk about it
but if there's a dance in i can say some
things there's a dance in fortnite
called boneless if you search no bones
dance on youtube
uh it's a big thing nathan did a long
time ago it was stolen by
hundreds of people for many reasons and
maybe a video game did that
i can't oh anymore and i wish
uh it sounds like daddy's about to get
paid
no you should talk to backpacks
yeah did it did it wait didn't someone
else sue them in one backpack kid the
floss floss dance
i know everything about all those cases
because i was deep into it uh they're
settled out of court for not enough at
all
but it's like better than what you
didn't have so well hold
yeah so so so so i'm assuming so
actually let's do some ops because i'm
interested in this so if i do dad and
then type what or nathan barnett just
search just search no bones dance
no bones dance
yeah you're right ian i mean you have
you have a very unique dance style
that's pretty much
so this is this is from
[Music]
so you might need to mute 11 years ago
mute this you meet the music thank you
you can see the dance yeah thanks for
the heads up on that
yeah
okay so my music is okay you can play my
stuff
i do like this
so that it has made it's if you search
party as a gif or if you search so many
words it's the first thing that comes up
so i always say i'm an a-list celebrity
in the gift world which is below movies
television commercials internet it's
like a barrel oh okay oh i know this
dance right
i've seen absolutely yeah there's a
dance in fortnite called um boneless
oh that's something [ __ ]
and never was anything paid so let's see
boneless link in the description
exact
oh so you know what you know what dude
why they got us they make so much money
why they got to steal this [ __ ] they
could easily just contact residuals i'd
be a millionaire for sure well yeah and
you should be like why should they be
ripping off
why
still to this day trying to make rent by
throwing getting a thousand views on
youtube and it's like 20 years of this
and it's like i'm still here but if i if
i just gotten tagged in things like a
guy f jerry on instagram and taurus
touristy would always post my stuff i
never got tagged
those guys i tried man i made a whole
video about those [ __ ] scum yeah and
yeah they just kept doing this thing
for 20 years legitimately honestly
yeah i i can't thank ian and any send
off like legitimately this is the
biggest day of my entire life like this
is all led to this
that all this all the failures and all
the stealing i'm like gonna show
everyone like i'm still around and i'm
not stopping 41 and i have more energy
than everybody
this is gonna make me cry yeah
no dad forever bro yeah
the love of my life passed away about
nine months ago and like who did wait
what i mean
yeah i'm like
who passed away
the love of my life uh
i'm not trying to get into any weird
stuff but like i'm just talking to you
guys i'm getting amped up right now and
i just this is legitimately going to be
the biggest day of my life and i'm going
to do it for her so
and i'll ever get redemption for
everything that's happened to me over 20
years
can i ask what what what uh what
happened
uh it was very unexpected and
uh we didn't really know i don't i don't
want to say like how but um
it uh is just
very unexpected and
a surprise and a shock and i have her
dog here now and
uh it's just
dang it's just been it's been gnarly
it's uh
just someone you were with for
for a long time
but then it was like off because she
needed to just be away and but we were
still best friends and like talked every
second and the last thing i talked to i
was on america's got talent last year
and uh doing those the dances you just
saw and uh that was the last thing i
talked about was showed her the trailer
that came out they were using me for
promotion on jimmy kimmel i'm like
everywhere and it was like my image time
mccall was talking about me specifically
and
uh if you search keith agt you can see
and the last thing she said to me was i
sent her the still i was crying on the
show because i was crying because i wish
she was there and i was i texted her
right after i was like i wish you and
frankie were here and that's the dog who
i have right now that like we were the
families like the three of us and i was
like i was crying my eyes out on stage
in front of the judges
after i danced because i just wish she
was there i was there alone and it's
just like i was i'm a very emotional
person anyway so i kind of get worked up
and uh i sent her the picture because
she knew why i was crying because she
wanted to come to the second round i
sent her a picture of me crying and she
said it's beautiful because she knew the
whole deal and she's like i'm coming to
the second one uh my second performance
i made to the second round and then she
passed away so i was at the second round
alone with her and the whole thing fell
apart as a producer so i totally messed
with everything and didn't let me do
what i wanted and i looked like an idiot
and
anyways i'm getting i'm kind of tangent
here and i know you got i don't mean to
like to derail your show but
this this fight will do be everything
for me and i'm gonna come out on top
and uh i'm not i'm not messing around so
matt you're screwed
sorry i'm so sorry yeah
i tend to ramble and i just don't want
to like get up don't worry if i'll cut
you off
my friends are definitely losing their
mind that i'm on the show right now
well i'm very sad by that story that's
just that's that's that's the worst yeah
it's been rough i mean everyone goes
through stuff like this and i don't mean
to like you know i don't mean to like
it's not true it's not important it's
special but i know it's just part of
life and
uh it's just very early you know so
anyway yeah i think she's amazing yeah i
think it's important people here you
know
everyone's journey you know to get here
i think that's like
you know what we want to emphasize a lot
and i appreciate you sharing that nathan
yeah i think you guys are doing a really
good job like
anissa and ian are like this is amazing
like this is not like any of those
stupid other fake youtube boxing events
this is like real people real things and
i like that they're saying they want
it's all about the journey and like the
respect for boxing because the journey
is it like they're saying every fight is
a story and like not everyone's gonna be
able to see that and likely ian's
putting on a documentary so you can get
a taste of what's going on about all the
fighters
no i mean we weren't able to uh you know
probably i mean we're going to try to
visit everyone and try to get insight
but it'll probably mostly be me but
we'll have tertiary characters coming
through make your own documentary yeah
all right that's what i've been doing
i've been filming everything and
uploading that and that's what we've
been encouraging people to do because
obviously it is a journey and yeah you
know no one will be able to tell it
better than the person experiencing it i
have your oh man so so you last year
were on america's got talent this has
nine million views bro that's funny yeah
so it was higher than that on facebook
and everything else like it was legitly
the show was telling me i'm it was the
most viewed thing that they had on the
whole like the whole season and then uh
uh a bunch of other acts came out there
was um
scrolling nightbird who i became very
good friends with on the show she was
like the big thing because her she was a
beautiful singer and she was her voice
was amazing she had cancer and she just
recently passed away about a year after
get that push or that like i am i mean
i'm an actor i have an agent and all
that stuff and i'm going out but like
i didn't get my living in living color
to like really jump off you know spring
me off so i'm just going hard with it so
this was my opportunity to try to show
that to the world
and like okay let's hire this guy to put
him on an nbc sitcom or something you
know and it was right there and then it
was clear i was just used to be the
weirdo in the beginning and then throw
me away when they don't need me anymore
because they really botched my whole act
and kept injecting things they wanted me
to do which messed up my whole routine
it was just a disaster and like it
wasn't all what i wanted to do so you
had this big plan for the second round
and they were like
and they were like no you got to do it
you got to put in these certain elements
that you didn't think would work
yeah i had three different words that
they worked with changed character that
was one that would make the judges go
wait is this the same guy like they
wouldn't even know it was me and then at
the end it would the reveal would be
like oh this has been the same guy
through the whole season and his actual
talent was acting which you can't really
do
that's what they wanted you to do
i i was an idea of mine that was one
idea the first original idea was just
he's dancing again but keep it very
simple under a spotlight he's dancing he
just focused on the moves kind of like a
napoleon dynamite type thing so the
mainstream audience can get it and
understand it but they wanted they go so
no you need to wear like a shiny
glittery suit and you need to wear like
these and i was like well the character
doesn't do that the character gets his
clothing cbs like yeah
it's about him being him
and they really wanted to hype it up and
they had all this like stuff falling in
front of the lens with balloons and the
camera movement and you couldn't even
see me and they're like you gotta move
all around the stage to all these points
to hit these spots and that that took
time away from actual dancing had to
literally travel and run across the
stage and it became a disaster it was
just a cluster and it didn't work and it
made me look bad and it was perfect
because then simon could say what they
wanted him to say like oh this was a
disaster but if thanks to you [ __ ]
and focus on the moves yeah it would
have been like oh this guy can still
dance and do crazy stuff and i was gonna
throw a backflip in which i did at the
end and you couldn't even see the back
foot because they cut the camera and i
was like this is that
so anyways that's not cool yeah lots of
things about like
this type of tv like shark tank and
yeah all the idol shows and all that
they're just so
uh they do so much behind the scenes
that are this is bad even our personal
like journey with like trying to get
traditional media involved with this
we've had like quite a few people where
we're like
this is not who we want to hire we had
to go through like quite a few none of
them get it they all have like they're
weird it's incredible isn't it how and
they and like these executives that
[ __ ] up your routine they get paid so
much money i know for what what did they
do
so i had this one producer who like
usually on all reality you have that you
have like a producer that sticks with
you the whole time and they work with
you i like thought i became friends with
this guy and he was like he worked for
wwe and i'd done some stuff with wwe and
he saw my wwe stuff and he's like hey
i'm a fan of the character i know all
about it i know your stuff you did with
dolph ziggler so i was like oh this guy
gets it he's cool and they really make
you think like they're they're your
friend and like okay this guy's like
every other la producer every hollywood
producer and then
when i go you go he took a picture with
me before i went out and he only took a
picture with me and this other magician
who got cut so i was like oh i didn't
take pictures of any other contestants
he had but after the fact i was like oh
he took pictures because he knew who was
getting cut and it's supposed to be a
real actual vote
he didn't even say goodbye to me after i
he didn't even come up to me like hey it
was great working with me for for nine
months whoa he didn't say anything to me
i was like okay screw this place these
people don't care about me
it was planned he knew who was going and
they got what they wanted so the
pretense is that the audience votes
and i have other reasons why in logic
that really shows how the votes do not
count this is whole longest i can't get
into it it's just too long of estimation
but like the time zones people west
coast votes don't even count technically
because new york is watching three hours
earlier so it's like they don't even
mention that in the lower thirds or
anything to like
say so it's just like how does this even
work
but whatever
it's well it's really tv what do you
expect the thing is i got i didn't i i
walked into it not being excited i was
like whatever it's some some views maybe
some people subscribe to me they don't
tag you they don't put in the
description they'll do anything so it
didn't do much for me until i commented
and let and hoped it got pinned or hoped
that a lot of thumbs up brought some
people to me so that's like me basically
scrounging for subscribers i feel like a
loser and it just didn't do much for me
because they just don't really care they
don't push you they don't promote you
yeah and then i got excited thinking oh
my life might actually change i might
get envies they talk to me like oh yeah
we can get you a first pitch a first
person deal with nbc and like i've i've
been in la for 16 years i know how it
works i've worked with many networks for
many many years and i'm thinking all
right sure pal sure sure and then i
start getting excited thinking oh well
i'm on jimmy fallon and now i'm on every
talk show they're showing my clip only
like okay they are taking me seriously
and then i felt that's when i got mad
when i was like okay this was all lie
because i felt like i was duped and i
didn't want to get excited and then they
made me excited that's [ __ ] crazy
yeah it's interesting to hear just these
stories because i know a lot of people
are so just hate hollywood i've never
really dealt with like the hollywood
mechanic because we've always kind of
done our own thing right but that's just
that's terrible that's [ __ ] up reality
is a whole different thing though like i
work with comedy central and adult swim
a lot and like it's different it's more
like creative people crafting some sort
of art of some kind but reality is like
take anyone you can slap together a
product not like a show of any kind so
it's like you kind of take it with a
grain of salt but i just got excited
because it was so many views were coming
in so fast and my keith's instagram was
actually getting looked at and
but whatever sorry dan i'm over it now
and now i'm pumped about this it was
actually almost exactly a year ago so
it's like every year i had something fun
to do and this year it's the it's boxing
so can i just go pee yeah
yeah oh cool
you guys go pee i have to pee but i'll
sit and i want to talk to you are you
good yeah i'm good is this the one i've
got at this video up here is this the
one they [ __ ] up or is this a
different one
keith brings his most dangerous
performance to hgt yeah oh my god it was
so bad this is this whole magic thing
that made no sense it was pointless
oh god there's so much confetti
no
so much confetti
heidi klum is getting so this whole yeah
oh no not heidi she's getting up
so none of this was your idea they kept
telling me that there's a guy named tape
face that was on america's got talent
who was like an alternative comedic
magician sort of
like act and people loved him like he
blew up yeah yeah and they're like
you're the next tape face we you're
going to be that guy and he went all the
way through the whole season i was like
okay i'll listen to them and i'll go
along with what they're saying because
they must know what they're talking
about i kind of let go and stop fighting
because i don't want to be the difficult
contestant and once i did it was like
okay this is a dumb guillotine thing
with a really there was no punch line to
the joke it was just like okay never
mind and then it killed time and
everyone was confused and it just was so
bad in so many levels
so yeah it was dumb that's uh god that
sucks so it sucks to go out on someone
else's idea you know at least if you go
out on yours you know
i know i had two different angles that i
thought would have worked that were very
different it was just focusing on the
dancing and another thing that was more
like andy kaufman where it's like whoa
this has never been done because you
can't go out and show acting as a talent
on a show like that because like when
you go and do a monologue it's gonna be
weird and boring and like you're not
actually invested because you know the
person is doing a monologue you can't
you know you can't act as a talent on
that show and i thought the only way to
do it would be like some sort of sasha
baron cohen thing where like they don't
know the guys in character and then they
go wait
when they're told oh he was the nerd he
was the peg leg guy he was
uh this guy like oh my gosh that's
that's insane and then i i reveal at the
end i'm an actor my talent wasn't
dancing it wasn't magic it was acting
and then they have to be like well i
don't know what to think i thought the
producers were thought that was cool and
they were like it's too confusing for
the home audience and i was like yeah i
guess but like
i don't know i feel like what if we put
your head in a room yeah it's always
like anything that's remotely like you
have to think about it or makes you
think they don't want that ever
ever not at all
they just want people to go funny bald
man dance they they wanted us like we
these two guys that we talked to
originally to help us like produce this
boxing event they wanted to take us to
the cayman islands
to like have all the boxers fight in the
cayman islands
and we were like why and they're like
well it's the cayman islands
why is it cheaper or something no they
they literally they just thought it
would be cool
to take everyone to the cayman islands
it was like their whole thing they
wouldn't get off of it and that was kind
of what that was their whole thing we
were like this is not it we would have
never came back they're like yo we
should like burning or what what fire
festival and they'd be like yo we have
this island that's owned by pablo
escobar that
we'd love to throw an event set up a
couple of tents
there's a lot of events that are
happening boxing events i'm hearing
youtube boxer events that are happening
in dubai yes that is very i don't want
to go there
i wouldn't go ahead for that [ __ ] dubai
i mean i don't like dubai he's in for
that they have slave labor there bro
they straight up have [ __ ] slaves
yeah no
people people act like it's totally cool
to go there it's it's like it's bad it's
they have literal slaves there that they
trick into going there that builds all
their towers and [ __ ] yeah a couple of
people talk about it like they steal
their passports and stuff them into
rooms together and like don't die from
call them hostage and yeah they're they
bring workers from like indonesia
southeast asia
and then they steal their passports it's
basically a slave class yeah no
i mean they're they're on dubai then
also i'm pretty sure it's illegal to be
gay there yeah i'm not sure i'm sure if
you kiss a dude you get publicly
executed there's a lot of a surprisingly
high number of countries where it's like
punishable by death
that's cool we'd like that wow that's
what i'm saying like people go there
like it's all like it's like a totally
chill normal place it's not it's not a
[ __ ] good place
thank you
i was just ignorant towards i had no
idea oh sorry i wasn't trying to call
you out
i just got there i i always get
triggered
yeah no that's fair they're also
building like this weird utopia city
there that's all like
you know tech friendly and that's the
whole point is to make it seem like uh
it's for rich people to feel yeah
healing place to go to and normal yeah
sorry dad i didn't mean to call you out
i thought you did no no you didn't you
are the man no no i really didn't know
you are the man i didn't mean to do that
at all i thought you said [ __ ] dubai and
so then i got i just joined the
train yeah yeah cause there were
apparently there's youtube boxing events
happening there that's what i'd heard
there there's a lot of boxing in mma in
general um michael you've explained that
to us why that is right why uh there's
there's just a lot of money in dubai so
they bring over the fighters for that
yeah also no visas right no travel visas
oh yeah well it's just uh oh so that's
that's what like the ufc was doing with
uh they they made an area with um
in the united arab emirates where they
had like their own fight island is what
they called it where they would just
bring people in it was just that they
did that because uh
it was um lacks on like they they could
make their own um bubble for covid so
that's why they did that yeah it was
pretty much just so they could have an
island where they could fly fighters
into from around the world legally
because they couldn't bring them into
america at the time
well anyway dad everyone go subscribe to
dad we're rooting for dad thank you
thank you forever
watson
i always hear that in wendy williams
yeah death to all of them
are we wishing death to matt watson or
just uh some light injuries light
injuries all of them
light injuries uh a wake-up call i might
go harder on the next the next fight
which i'm hoping i should say to you
ethan oliver tree no he knows what he
did to dad so did oliver tree [ __ ] you
up [ __ ] you over
oliver tree is one of my nemesis
everybody i know hates him
tell him dad's coming for him i'll let
him know
thank you thank you
i know where he lives we can roll up
together
all right well thanks for having me on
this is thanks
thank you
all right thank care good luck out there
we're rooting for you yeah thank you
very much baby's getting it thanks maybe
he's getting it all the way
bye-bye by the way thanks dad by the way
i did not mean to call him out i feel
bad about that i don't feel like no no
no i think it was yeah yeah he just i
just don't want him to feel bad like he
came on and i was like [ __ ] you dad
about
dubai
he's an adult he's 40.
one of the uh
one of the commentators for the fight
asked us to felt like excel sheet with
just basic info about ourselves and uh
dad was the first one to fill it out and
it looks like you filled out matt's
section as well he says my name is matt
watson and i'm afraid to fight dad but
i'm weak
that's awesome
all right let's have some fun now uh
and talk about
your beef with keemstar
that's so fun i love keemstar is one of
my favorite people to [ __ ] on
uh he's such a pathetic goon
and uh you actually you made this great
video
why i hate influencer boxing uh-huh
and uh you did call out keemstar a lot
what the did you edit and so you like
that what the hell
that's right oh they you know you hold
them all that's fat logan paul oh i see
and fat austin mcbroom and jacked
handsome yeah beautiful baby face
babe pure beautiful skin
that's awesome thanks
video are you no i just wanted to see
what well you just said basically that
keemstar
well what do you think about him in the
space with his whole happy punch
[ __ ] and with him and fussy tube i
think he enjoys an element of boxing
that i don't really enjoy um he's just
like very
dramatic
he likes the drama and he obviously
makes money from the drama so
i understand why he's a little bit
biased toward it
sure he wants he wants goofy
embarrassing [ __ ] he wants people to
like
just kind of like throw all caution to
the wind embarrass himself just do
whatever it takes to get a couple more
views and clicks
we don't feel like we need to do that at
all this is a very [ __ ] tough event
like people
like
if you want people to experience like
humiliation and embarrassment and like
putting it all on the line it's already
happening like we're boxing an event
where we have the possibility of getting
knocked
out
uh
you know it's also
like it's way more like he wants jerry
springer yeah right right like that's
kind of like jerry springer but with
like severe head injuries
basically but i don't think anybody else
wants that no no we you're already
asking people to do a lot and i think if
if if keemstar had like an actual boxing
event that he was putting on and he said
like hey guys i'm doing jerry springer
boxing
and you had our event i think most
people would be like oh i'm going with
your guys's event not keemstars because
that's like that's so much to ask it's a
person it's also like
shocking at how much support we've
gotten for the direction we're i mean we
were at sushi last night and the sushi
chef like came up to ian and was like
telling him how like excited he is about
this event and he's never cared about
boxing before i mean it's a different
audience right like but
i i mean we're kind of betting on the
idea that this audience is actually much
bigger
than the audience that wants a jerry
springer direction yeah trashy
yeah it's trashy i i well the thing that
i liked about this video which you guys
should watch is just how much you
highlight that how much of a serious
event it is and how
you know you want good fights safe
fights
and like i actually thought you made
really good points not not just to trash
keemstar but just to say like
this is what he wants which is trashy
and lame and pathetic and like he's a
loser and
like he'll nobody will ever love him
stuff like that
and then
you were like uh
you know well and he could only the only
woman will be with him are like 18
because they don't have enough life
experience stuff like that and then he
and then you're like well our event is
actually super professional
the fight itself is enough and i think
that's a good point you have to be 18
year old
yeah so that would exclude his friends
the also like the big thing is is like
we have so many creative very successful
youtubers and streamers that we know
can do really cool like wwe level like
interesting stuff like even like if you
look at ego raptor and like harley's
trash talk it's funny yeah i'm sure i
did a thing and uh odd ones out trash
talk on twitter is funny like the clips
that ian's uploaded are yeah these are
all a bunch of talent super talented
you're not gonna attract like actually
serious talented people if it's like
[ __ ] knock him out [ __ ]
no gloves it's it's also like a lot of
weird mixed signals if you look at um
there's a clip of uh i think there's
fousey and keemstar are doing a press
conference for youtubers versus tick
tockers
super awkward that was awesome at broom
one right yeah very successful by the
way
uh there was one of the creators who was
like called out
like in the press conference and like
embarrassed because he had texted his
opponent like you want to like start
this like beef this fake beef or
whatever because they were obviously
feeling the pressure to promote promote
train wreck and they they don't give
them options it's like no you gotta
you've got a beef that's the only way to
to do it
and then they use that as like a jumping
off point to be like
oh yeah this guy's over here faking beef
what a loser and it's like that's
what you're all doing yeah like don't
like you're the one that like pushed him
to doing it yeah yeah it's such an
awesome so they called out one of the
fighters
during the press conference yeah michael
lee i think his name is he uh he's a
tick talker and it's just like
the questions they ask too are all
really weird it's clear that keemstar
well it's clear that he knows nothing
about boxing i don't even understand why
oh but one thing i was telling you guys
before the show i think most of our
audience know the reason that keemstar
and fousey are doing this is because of
[ __ ] ryan kavanagh the guys that's
suing me four times
for uh no clue that's not awesome yeah i
was wondering like where i just thought
like keemstar had a good idea like i had
like legitimately
just like yeah because like you know the
youtube drama space i mean one it's
dwindling because a lot of us are
growing up to be honest and just like
it's becoming less of a thing also
people just care about it less it's
getting pushed less by youtube so i
thought like keemstar was making a
really smart business decision to be
like okay well if i switch into boxing
that's inherently dramatic
then like i can like continue to do this
so i thought he partnered with fousey
and that's what they were doing and i
was like oh wow like they seem to have a
pretty good system interesting idea oh
yeah knows ryan cavanaugh okay because
you know he's behind the whole triller
fight club thing yeah
by the way
we
wanted to we originally were talking to
a bunch of people including triller and
they were told us at the time they
wanted to do this conveyor belt
thing where they just have like
youtubers come on on a card once a month
once a month okay
um
and we were like what that seems like
literally the worst idea well too
frequently like yeah way too freaking
you can't type anything up there's like
it seems silly you're gonna injure
someone too like what are you gonna like
well they're desperate i don't know if
you know i follow ryan cavanaugh
his company lost a billion dollars last
year bro a billion dollars he's a
[ __ ] prolific loser
yeah they're doing something right now
called so you think you can fight or
something
so it's meant to be like an american
idol but for fighting or some [ __ ] like
that oh really i haven't seen really
bizarre i think they're yeah they're
trying to own the space but it's very
risky and dangerous well it's also
so hard if you don't know youtubers
personally like i think the only reason
why we're able to do this is because we
know influencers
yeah but like um they have right now
they're trying to get people to fight
bryce hall so like they tried to get the
island brothers they said they'd pay him
a million dollars oh trailer yeah oh
yeah i always see them hanging out i
always see kavkavan
uh did you know that rank kavanaugh
falsified his sexual uh
assault mmo i didn't know that yeah no
it's not even it's not even defamation
to say it's on record yeah when he he
owned a huge uh film production company
relativity which he bankrupted like he
utterly bankrupted that company
he went yeah so he's a horrible
businessman but what's interesting is
that during the bankruptcy he hired a
president
super high paying job and he wanted to
fire him without giving him a severance
so he
falsified a memo
saying that he had been sexually
harassing people
at the at work
so to give a pretense for firing him and
then the guy sued him and they found out
when they audited the the
and questioned people that ryan
cavanaugh [ __ ] falsified that
document bro the last person who falls
to buy the document his name was cav cav
cav so now we call him kavkav on the
show
yeah
and he doesn't face any
what well he lied under oath and uh they
settled out of court he had to pay him
like 11 million bucks or something yeah
he's he's a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
actually
but yeah i like to say that any chance i
got he's suing me four times they're
trying to get they had like they tried
to get some buzz about ben askren like
bryce hall fighting uh ben askren and
what who's gonna watch that like ben
askins already got the matt biggest l
ever i would watch he's like okay boys
and him fight though the parallels both
at the same time now that's a [ __ ]
[ __ ] right after the other oh no i
want two on one
when we went to the jake paul event we
were sitting on the the floor and all of
a sudden we just heard like booing like
in unison booing from was it ryan
cavanaugh came out
it was the island boys and they were
watching yeah right floors we were so
confused we were like why is everyone
they were throwing drinks at them like
oh my god
that is yeah wait why does everyone hate
themselves i don't i don't remember
they're kind of goofy but i think they
yell at their girlfriends oh yeah it was
around that time that all those clips oh
he got his ass beat by his girlfriend
apparently he hit her and then there's
just a video of him crying and begging
her one of the island boys
yeah yeah
actually something about ryan cavanaugh
since he's in the boxing world you know
it's kind of relevant if you type his
name in google
it
this is important so if you go if you
type his name in google
actually the second website that pops up
is one that we made does ryan cavanaugh
look like harvey weinstein oh i remember
that yeah so it's number two on the
search results it goes between one and
two
and uh
well it turns out the public is confused
on a poll we took of ten thousand voters
uh
a huge like i don't know 95 percent said
that they do look alike
here you can see if you slide between
them um
i mean the resemblance is uncanny coach
i mean you're not familiar with any of
this do you think they look alike
spot on it's like crazy right twins
right might as well be twins um and then
you know there's actually photos of them
together you can see ryan cavanaugh he's
kissing him on the head he loves him
wait yep here they are together
here he is you know he loves the guy and
yeah
but the kiss on the head really says it
all doesn't it that's crazy yeah it is
he was like probably sniffing his hair
and everything for sure yeah
uh you know he has duis two of them
in fact he can't he
yeah that's what happens when you're
rich that sounds like right horn i know
it's a being a thing apparently wet and
reckless i never heard that people i
know they get dui right yeah
we we had a we had a dui run in recently
uh in our lift oh yeah our lyft driver
had no [ __ ] blowing into the [ __ ] while
he was driving
yeah it was so bad we were already late
to the airport did he get
we were late to get to the airport right
it took like 20 minutes so we're in
there right and we're driving it's very
it's just it's a messy car whatever
we're driving really fast on the florida
highway and all of a sudden we just hear
like
like this really loud beep and ian's
like that's too loud to be a phone like
what is that and the guy ignores it and
then it goes off again and we see him
reach for something and he pulls like
i've seen the the dui
machine
so he had to breathe into it while he's
like on the highway with us and he said
like i might have to pull over he said
something about pulling over so we
thought that like he had like maybe had
a couple of drinks and we were going to
be late for the airport it was the most
horrific it was almost florida so once
you get a dui they install if you want
to drive they make you check in yes and
if you if you don't pass the car shuts
off
technology actually yeah well ryan
kavanagh he doesn't drive anymore he had
to get a driver because i think he lost
his life actually one of the dui's was a
hit and run too oh my god yeah
are they okay
yeah no there was no injuries
uh here i'll read it to you in october
2008 while on probation for an earlier
conviction of dui because these these
have all been cleared by our lawyers so
these are good oh okay nice yeah these
are clean well on probation for an
earlier conviction of dui uh kavanaugh
was arrested for drunk driving speeding
and driving with a suspended license
from our earlier conviction oh so
there's nothing about the hit and run
but that did happen
uh he also sits around the topic oh this
is what i was saying he lied under oath
yeah yeah what's a ponzi scheme about
okay so well this one this is what he's
suing us about so i'll just be
i'll read this this was approved here
2019 elon spar signed a complaint under
oath alleging that kavanaugh persuaded
him to go into business together under
false pretense the suit was resolved out
of court this story was covered uh by
variety in a an article titled ryan
cavanaugh accused by his ex partner of
running a ponzi scheme i see
so
this he's suing me for defamation he's
suing me for a copyright infringement
he's suing me for tortious interference
that one we won already we're we're
countersuing him for legal fees
and he and he's suing us to remove this
website he's saying we're impersonating
him it's like a hobby like a like it's a
good time legal hobby
yeah it's a good time so but i should
say yeah that it was resolved at a court
and elon spar uh said that he did not uh
do a ponzi scheme
um
yeah
there you go even though by the way it
is worth of telling you ian
that um
elon spar under oath said he was running
a ponzi scheme
but then
not under oath said he wasn't doing a
ponzi
think about it
thank you
his uh his former babysitter suing him
for unpaid wages what 175 000 unpaid
it's a lot of babysitting hours well
it's a night nurse so she so yeah you
know they commit it's a big deal they
commit themselves to you for like a year
yeah it's a salary right yeah
and then so you know he's he apparently
he lost custody of his kids because he's
a [ __ ] alcoholic maniac and then he's
like well i'm not going to pay you yeah
he's a piece of [ __ ] right i don't know
about the custody thing i'm just
assuming that's what happened
um he sent me this dm oh okay i'm just
going to wrap it up here but here you go
that is the force of nature
that's harvey weinstein of course
that is the force of nature oh you know
what's my favorite thing that we gotta
add love is that he [ __ ] went to
habitat humanity
did a whole speech and was honored and
gave him a huge check for a million
bucks and he never donated the money no
we love we gotta add that
we gotta add him on that right now
there's a whole thing it's so [ __ ]
good you never you never donated it and
then they bitched him they're like what
the [ __ ] and he ended up giving him like
ten thousand dollars only
he's a good guy and that is a force of
nature that's like a bottom list he
really is a force of nature though he is
destructive absolutely
yeah we also made a game i don't know if
you if you when you go home later
if you go home later and you want to
play the game
uh you can test your skills
yeah so so you tell me
do you think that this is is that ryan
or harvey no that's
right good job you guys got it
come on here we go ready
go ahead that's harvey harvey yeah you
guys are good
you guys are good too thick
yeah last one the only difference is the
weight go ahead oh that's hard uh harvey
oh see that was harvey oh nice try nice
it's more challenging than it looks yeah
the angle makes it harder i think head
on you can see the goiter
you know because we're doing a public
service so there it is if you guys want
to go google his name brian cavanaugh
it's just the it's the second one
it's actually hard to
miss love that for him
oh yeah let's talk let's look at this
dumbass but don't you love that like
i've got beef with with ryan cavanaugh
and then keemstar is what i think
happened slides into his dms
and uh they become friends and now he's
paying him to promote boxing sounds like
awesome [ __ ] like he hates me too well
dan always says that it's like the
league of of uh
they're forming the legion
all of ethan's enemies keep coalescing
and then like and trisha apparently got
involved somehow and was talking to ryan
kavanaugh
we don't know about that
well like in the last okay in the
lawsuit against me what i do know i
don't know if they talked but what i do
know is in the lawsuit against me he
included excerpts of how i [ __ ] how i
uh harassed keemstar and trisha
and i thought that was interesting
okay whatever who cares
everyone's heard us a thousand times on
the show
he's my favorite
you know recently i thought we were in
somewhat good terms you know you have an
event i've been trying to talk about
your event as much as possible so this
is in response to your video yeah yeah
yeah i can already tell he's so sad does
it like
not okay you know i think any says good
insider yeah i
so i have a relative with like i'm not
saying he has bpd but i have a relative
with bpd and i think a piece of me felt
really sad watching this because like i
genuinely think
i don't think keemstar like a lot of the
time understands when he throws stones
like i don't think he
like understands when he's doing things
that are hurting people so then when
somebody responds with the same energy i
think he feels genuinely like he's being
attacked and then he gets like then he's
like well now i have to fight um and it
like
i think it
you know keemstar aside anybody in the
like when he was talking on the phone it
did kind of make me sad like genuinely i
think that's a that's a generous
interpretation but there is a lot of
sadness there yeah i think he respects
ian a lot more he really wants to be
your friend i think he wants to be ian's
friend yeah and i i think he was happy
that ian was reaching out to him and uh
felt like they had mended that and i
think he feels betrayed um but like ian
i mean he's a critical guy like of every
you know he's going to say what yeah i
guess in fairness like
i'm sure you'll play the video but
the the points he makes are like
they're they're i guess valid in
keemstar's world but i just don't feel
like he
he really
didn't click yeah he didn't really
understand that like the things he's
been saying like it is hurtful to me to
suggest that we're like promoting the
show or the you know creator clash in a
bad way
um so like i've been listening to what
he's saying you know i'll listen to the
the twitter spaces that he runs i'll be
like that's [ __ ] and i'm i'm like
storing that i'm like i'm gonna [ __ ]
talk about that he's been talking [ __ ]
a little bit okay he's been i mean i
shouldn't say talking [ __ ] he's been
talking [ __ ]
running the show yeah he feels like
there's not enough drama he said like he
feels like we're promoting it wrong
we're not going to make the right amount
of money well he has an enormous uh
well of experience right with to speak
from yeah the previous ticktock versus
the youtuber yeah he was a part of that
right
they were like bankrupt none of the
fighters got paid so yeah that's why
it's like i just don't
he doesn't need to do it it's like i
don't mind him talking about the show
and promoting and i think that's helpful
but [ __ ] like all the extra [ __ ] he
puts on it is just way too much yeah
yeah i mean i think you're right though
there's a lot of sadness there i mean
he's an orphan i don't mean that as an
insult it's just a statement of fact and
that is that's that's a lot to deal with
i think like you know that that brings a
lot of of damage yeah i i don't know i
think the older i get the more i like to
understand like genuinely that people on
the internet a lot of them like a lot of
people aren't
i had a therapist say to me like most
people don't wake up trying to ruin
other people's days like that's a very
good and then there's kimchi
but like there's a very so you try to
interpret as much as possible that like
when somebody's doing something even if
it's hurtful
most of the time they're doing it as a
defense mechanism even if it's true it's
definitely a defense mechanism so like i
think we we actually watched that when
we were eating poke and it genuinely
made me feel i've i felt
[Laughter]
i thought you were going to spit up your
fish or something i just like i think i
think
i don't know i know if i was getting
sick from the post yeah i felt nauseous
yeah it was the raw fish or keemstar
let's say i agree with the nissan i feel
like that's where the whole beef with
ethan and keem started as well as he
thought when he came on the show they
would be buddy buddy i agree the problem
with the man is like we had a good time
or i mean i i was i was brutally honest
with him but it was good yeah and like i
apologize so he got super mad at me
because i was like i know you guys are
mad i talk to keemstar as well you don't
like him
but even though you hate him and i hate
him too which come off harsh but
whatever and but like it's he's
interesting and let's hear him out and i
was like he was like [ __ ] you you [ __ ]
and i was like you know i'm sorry it was
too harsh i erased the comment i did
everything to like be a normal and like
he would just never let this go like i
tried you know it's the betrayal then he
tried to ruin my [ __ ] life or the
feeling of betrayal i'm not saying that
you did
i mean that man has you know well anyway
let's watch it we'll help you promote
your event i had you on the twitter it's
gonna be hard though to be like uh how
old is he's in his he's four just turned
four yeah it's gotta be hard to be 40
and just have like luck just a loveless
life you know
so sad yeah no i'm right i'm just giving
him the benefit of the doubt i mean
that's why like each you know the only
girls that hang out with him are like
right out of high school
so there are some eighteen year olds you
saw him from afar you know
yeah jake paul he lost a lot of weight
didn't you yeah he he had like a whole
posse it was like a whole
train a parade there was like a bunch of
like
younger youtubers like in their career
or whatever and then just him in the
middle with like his
significant other and then take care of
them
and and we we had our masks on he's the
chaperone we had a but it was it was an
interesting sight it was kind of like
seeing a wild animal did they arrive in
a school bus
is it a field trip
but yeah i mean look it's got to be hard
i mean the guy has a bar in his basement
where he probably serves underage girls
alcohol and you know that's just what it
is when you can't hang out i did see
that video of him and fousey you guys
like reacting to that yeah
that was very interesting i did like i
loved i love when he was bringing out
like cheat cheeses and bacon wasn't that
so interesting and that was like his
food oh it wasn't bacon it was jerky it
was jerky eat a plate of maple syrup and
they were eating it with a fork i love
it it tastes like that
i feel like i haven't you could tell
fruit
not about it it's like this is some
white people kids i feel like boozy the
whole time was like trying to figure out
if it was halal or not what he was
eating
yeah but yeah that was awesome he just
said jerky that was like how keemstar
eats i mean the man is a [ __ ]
beast he literally just eats beef jerky
and maple syrup like who does that
except sasquatch
he lives in buffalo new york he lives in
the forest
he's a [ __ ] sash squash
about your event and plug your event
um you know it all comes down to selling
tickets selling pay-per-views that's
what these events are all about
and you're trying to do something
different i'm interested to see how it's
good gonna pan out
uh but in this new video it's like
it almost feels like we're at war
against keemstar you know i did use a
lot of keemstar clips
because he was the main
spokesperson for these points i've
occasionally hear it from other people
but not nearly as often as keemstar i'd
almost say it in every live space the
points that you're trying to combat are
what are um that uh starting some drama
is like strictly good right uh and like
when someone says like
drama is good for your event that like
has so many connotations because it's
like
yeah i agree
what am i going to do about that like
i'm not going to
the only way to make drama happen is to
either let it happen organically
or you fake it
and
like
i'm under the philosophy that you should
just let it happen organically this is
an example of it happening organically
keemstar says some [ __ ] that i totally
disagree with so i make a video about it
and that's exactly why i made the videos
because i'm like yeah this could totally
bring attention to my event and he even
addresses it in the video saying like
see this is good this drama is good i'm
like yeah it's good but it's not what
you had in mind right what you had in
mind was me and dr mike like
saying some cringe right but you guys
but you guys are both good dudes and
neither you are are interested in
juvenile drama it's cringe it's not
that's not the crowd yeah i mean
absolutely maybe keemstar's crowd would
want to watch that cringe but as far as
it coming across naturally like we got
some natural stuff going on uh uh dr
mike doesn't want to do the pro fight he
wants to do exhibitions
you know there you go that's some stuff
let's dig in we were genuinely shocked
by that though yeah they so yeah
yeah just we don't want to force it
keemstar
but you know there's a lot to be said
for good sportsmanship too like you know
people got people really love to see
like good sports
we also like found a bunch of secure
people like people that are secure in
their life happy right they're not young
like a lot of these guys that are doing
like a lot of this beef like they're
young they're not secure with themselves
right there's a lot of like weird stuff
that gets thrown out that's like
homophobic or sexist and
you get into some really strange stuff
like people talking about wanting to
[ __ ] the other person's wife or
girlfriend in front of them after the
fight and like just
gross right there's actually this moment
it was
i think it was tyson fury's dad
said some [ __ ] about um jake paul yeah
because it was tommy fury versus jake
paul i really wanted to see that fight
yeah um and his dad said some [ __ ] like
uh my son's gonna bend over your
girlfriend yeah something like that yeah
wow and it was just like
jake paul it was like the best response
jake paul could have ever gave which was
like that is super like cringy like not
so bad
interesting it was super mature and it
was like wow that's impressive yeah it
was like that was a separation of like
jake paul understood like what the level
is here the level of intensity yeah and
that was over the line and that was just
like all right but it's weird how often
things get accidentally like homophobic
like very like it's very strange
interesting like they love to call each
other gay or like sucking each other's
dicks or yeah but it's like in a way of
like shame
it's so that was the one that was like
bad yeah yeah
right that's the homophobia interesting
also like faking beef it's like that guy
probably wouldn't have headbutt the
other guy if they didn't like
rally these two up
it was kind of the same thing a little
bit with the tattoos that jake and
tyrone were gonna get right what did it
have to be it had to be i love jake paul
i love tyrone woodley yeah come on guys
like right i was going to say i think
with um
i think with a lot of the
drama people get lost in uh what sold
the fight in the first place it wasn't
the drama that sold the fight like when
ian was talking about earlier it's the
journey so i think people get confused
because they see people like conor
mcgregor or they see these other people
where they associate them with the drama
but
it wasn't the drama that made him big it
was the journey that made him big people
saw him come up from nothing to where he
was at and that's what attracted people
to him people were never attracted to
the fact when he's hitting an old guy in
a bar or these other things like when he
throws when he throws this when he
throws a dolly through a bus like those
are things people were only attracted to
that because of the journey that the
other people had been on or the journey
that led it to there it wasn't the drama
itself
and so i think people with fighting
they're like oh let's create this drama
which with a lot of fighters is a is a
mistake because there are a lot of
degenerates and if you try to fight like
do those types of things it's going to
lead to bad scenarios
so i think with what ian's saying it's
like
we're selling it for the journey of what
these people are going through and i
think that will attract people more than
drama but so many people think it's the
drama that sells when it's not the drama
it's people want to be they're attracted
to the journey of what this person went
through
and that's what they either relate to or
that's what they're against
um and say with like the whole
mayweather thing when they talk about
drama it's like it's it's not drama he
was playing a heel and that's a classic
like old school pro wrestling move to
get people interested we need the heel
and the we need to heal but we also need
a good guy and if there's two heels
it doesn't sell as well you need to have
like the drama but there has to be the
good guy and so um
a really good analogy i feel like is
like you can see a clip of a building
building exploding and you're not gonna
be like well that's awesome but in a
michael bay movie like with a lead up
and a story and like you understand
what's going on an exploding building if
you understand the context can be very
interesting but you don't need an
exploding building for people to care
about the movie right like it's just
like an extra thing that can happen yeah
it seems like the drama is like
it's not what people got there but it's
potentially something that keeps
people's attention yes and also like so
a lot of people don't like conor
mcgregor literally came from like
nothing he was talking about like he was
like oh i just slept in my bed all day
late and never got up and didn't do
anything i was a loser he says all the
time like i was a loser and then he's
like i decided i want to fight and he
started fighting and he became very
successful and like
the irish side of him like there's a lot
of things that sold him way before
right right right so
well that's all very interesting and
refreshing too actually yeah because
it's all been about
like kind of the trashy stuff so far so
i like this angle you guys are taking
you multi you made multiple points
that uh
you know you said something along the
lines like i don't like these fake bets
but you know who does keemstar and then
you play a clip where i'm criticizing
extremity for the bat being fixed
he's a canadian youtuber oh that's a
person okay fake you know versus the
houses and stuff and you can possibly
also
um
just to clarify what keemstar is saying
here i uh
uh
i don't like the fake bets or the real
bets and i i think that was uh pretty
clear in the video really what's he
talking about uh just that one of my
points was that i think it's very uh
oh the betting like i'm gonna bet you a
million bucks yes my house is yeah
specifically he's like a 21 year old
child he's like
all my house he's got two houses that he
wants you to know he has two houses sure
he just does a lot of rich kid type [ __ ]
yeah he was trying to bet his two houses
or that you know like i'll bet my two
houses versus your lamborghini what
that's just too hyperbolic it's not even
real no it's real he's got two houses no
i get that but did he give him the
houses they had a lawyer hold up a
document saying like we're signing today
like to prove that they it was a legal
bet but they didn't actually sign it
apparently so it didn't happen
um yeah it was just all like oh it's
coming it's coming it's happening right
you why don't you like that aspect
because i don't think it's interesting i
think that everyone who's at least all
of the adults generally watching
um
they
know that it's like not a real thing
right um in the first place and i don't
actually think it's that much more
exciting to know that someone is going
it's like they're in our house
like it's not that exciting i'm gonna
[ __ ] ruin your life yeah yeah i've
said that yeah you may as well say
you're gonna suck the other guy off if
you lose it's like why are you doing
well it's not and also i'm pretty sure
they're gonna fight hard no matter what
right it doesn't do anything and i've
said this a couple of times to people
like i think in our climate that we're
in right now where like there's most
people can't even afford like decent
housing to rent like having some 20 year
old be like i'm gonna give away two of
my houses is like not really the vibe
it's like totally fake confident as well
anyone with any type of radar watching
their press conferences you can tell
that these are like super insecure 20
year olds they do not think they have
what it takes to win at all right yeah
it's just like i'm going to present this
sort of they can't even back up their
trash talk
said boxing's not about knockouts and
then you bring up a point where i say
hey if you get the knockout it's like
you know the biggest plug in the world
what is wrong i don't understand what
what's wrong with what i'm saying you
know jarvis got the knockout in social
gloves
jarvis is one of the most sought of uh
boxers right now is that true
i i mean i mean i think people take him
seriously because he won yeah just like
people take wasabi seriously because he
won wasabi just won against deji i mean
jake paul didn't knock anyone out until
recently i've never heard of him what
i've never heard of him so i don't know
i mean i know who jarvis is but he's
just a youtuber yeah yeah i don't think
he's in demand well that's the problem
boxing i've never heard of it is uh
keemstar when when i was looking trying
to look for an opponent he did a twitter
poll on his own of like who would you
like to see idubbbz fight and he lined
up like four people
uh because he was convinced i needed to
fight like a nemesis if it wasn't
ricegum it had to be j station right and
i'm like i've never said a [ __ ] word
about j station i don't know anything
about him he doesn't even have a youtube
doesn't have a youtube presence he's
banned
it's like you are so stupid but they're
not even good opponents it's not good if
you think i should fight this but he put
that twitter twitter poll up who do you
think won playstation yeah yeah yeah it
was jefferson for nothing taylor holder
and some other ones dr mike and it's
like yeah like that's your audience like
of course keemstar's audience is going
to say j station
yeah it's like putting it out too super
highest yeah his obsession with wanting
to box me is awesome too actually what's
interesting is you invited him into the
gym and he bitched out yeah to spar i
mean that's the thing he's very
confident about talking about like
knockouts and head injuries but i i
feel the same way as ian did in that uh
you know if you're going to be so
confident about people giving each other
you know knockouts and concussions like
you should at least try it at least
yeah you know at least no i mean
concussions are not fun
it's the worst you feel like you don't
even know which way is up or down
really yeah and if you're gonna be yeah
involved with so much of the boxing
press and giving your like high level
takes about what should be done like
you should have some no experience yeah
yeah yeah that's a fair point i mean you
offered graciously for him to come down
and he bitched out big time he [ __ ]
cry
we would do it too and i know ian's not
ian's a very responsible spider you'd be
you heard him you would take him
graciously
to give him a genuine experience
michael's going to be chaperoning the
whole thing making sure i'm not going
crazy on him yeah
michael michael oh you're sorry yeah
yeah you might encourage him to go crazy
i just know you as coach
ian has accidentally uh dropped some
people with body shots you [ __ ] some
people up
it was an idea
it was an act did you feel bad yeah yeah
he's actually i don't know hurt a lot of
people with body shots you you got a
vicious body game yeah yeah yeah
should dr mike know that yeah we should
talk about this yeah maybe we shouldn't
talk about this anymore it's too late
how do you protect yourself no that's
good if he crouching yeah if he thinks
he needs to protect his body i'll just
go for the head
yeah you're supposed to use your arms
your elbows your movement your feet but
uh ian sneaks in body shots really well
so and and he uh and it's funny because
he won't realize it sometimes until
afterwards and like a week later
somebody's like man my rib has been
bruised all week or there was one guy
that was like man you completely stopped
me there and just stuff like that where
sometimes i don't think he realizes that
he like messed the guy up to the body
until afterwards and then the guys
or sometimes he doesn't even know in the
moment because he like i see it i'm like
oh crap you finished him you finished
him but he's like what
is it difficult as part of this new
hobby you're doing or profession if you
want to call it that as hurting people
it's a
yeah it's definitely like a tough mental
thing
right like when you get when i think
when i started sparring in the first
place or just getting involved and
punching towards someone like the pro
this prospect of like even connecting
with someone's face is like really
difficult like you don't want to do it
you're going to be punching in front of
their face the whole time i'm going to
be punching and these are like right
here because i'm like that's not a
normal human thing to do is
now he does it all the time
he'll be like in the kitchen and he'll
[ __ ] come up to me and just start
punching at me
like moving around my body i'm so
desensitized you're pretty talented
there so you gotta
yeah oh yeah yeah she is talented we
definitely have him like spar
uh safely though so we
like
intensity is always matched so normally
if somebody's in there and they're not
that good ian's not gonna
um up the intensity we're gonna make
sure that like we get safe work in but
if if somebody's in there really like
pushing the intensity then that's when
we'll that's when it will turn more into
a fight but uh usually we try to like
build them up i i don't have ian in
there throwing all out versus somebody
that doesn't know what they're doing
sure yeah so when he does like hit
somebody hard it was i like to say it
was very mutual that it got to that
point how do you prepare for like a real
fight then
you know what i mean because when you're
in the fight it's all out enough so
enough
and that's the thing right there's
there's fitness and then there's being
conditioned a lot of people will think
that they have the fitness to box a
certain amount of rounds but you really
have to be conditioned to actually fight
and to punch people as well as the
environment so that's why like they
already went they have the advantage
they've already been to the venue so now
we can kind of like visualize that
moment visualize being in the venue
because being conditioned for a fight is
much different than actually the fitness
levels for a fight and you can't
actually simulate it until you're really
in there so we just have to do
give him as much looks as possible like
i said sometimes it's technical
sometimes it's a hard fight so we we get
him through as many different moments
and as as possible before we go through
that experience he's he's seen fights
like i don't even think he's aware of
when he's like in a fight but there's
this one guy that he spars with very
regularly named ryan he's an mma guy
very good um where it's kind of like a
dark souls boss it's so funny like ian
will get this like really hard punch off
and then ryan will be like oh
we're doing this and he'll just like
start like just beating the [ __ ] out of
ian and he and he's like i don't know
what the [ __ ] happening he's gotten
better with it but it's cool to watch
because so you do you you you place
yourself against yeah yeah that's what
happens high-level fighters yeah yeah oh
yeah yeah yeah
some of the guys he spars with have been
sparring for 20 years um ryan ishmael is
like a pro mma fighter that he works
with but uh so it he he spars guys of we
we have a few people that are like a
little bit lower level so that way he
can actually see when he does well
because like she said what happens is
he'll do well against somebody that's
been in it for a long time and as soon
as you do well for somebody good they're
just going to take up their level and
exactly so and i don't expect like i
don't expect ian or ab to be winning
those rounds but if we can have sort of
progress yeah and just have progress
like
if if we can be successful in a few
moments in those rounds i take that as a
win so sometimes ian's and they're
getting beat up and he's looking at it
as a loss and i'm like well you did
these like several things well and i'm
more happy about that because dr mike
isn't a he hasn't he claims he's been
doing it for 10 years it's like he
hasn't been fighting for 20 years or 14
years or more like some of the people he
spars with or a b i'm sure spars with so
uh it's going to be a whole different
experience but
uh
to ask ian to be somebody that's been
doing this for 20 years legitimately
isn't a realistic ask to actually be
those guys isn't realistic just knowing
what it's like to be in there and yeah
not being shocked once you have to go in
there and fight this is keemstar right
now by the way we just got this photo
he's crying in his bar
box in his basement watching the podcast
yeah to add on to what michael said it's
like it's sometimes i'm afraid when i if
i like land a good hit and the whole
gym's like oh because i know then i'm
going to get my ass kicked
that
i'd landed is that's true then i just
get my [ __ ] rocked so yeah
oh that's that's a double-edged uh yeah
it was sweet to see ian earn the respect
there's this one guy that comes in he's
fully tatted out he's got like a neck
tattoo and everything comes in with
yeezys he's like a very like cool dude
or whatever he's been boxing for 14
years and he loves to spar and he never
took it lightly on ian right like the
first time they fought or sparred you
know like he was just like bopping him
in the face every five seconds and it
was cute to see
ian realize like oh i'm gonna stand here
and trade and punch back and they were
just beating the [ __ ] out of each other
and after you could tell that like gabe
had really he had earned the guys
respect and he was like it was just very
sweet to see that you know part of the
journey part of that journey yeah
sick
respect baby yeah you want a journey
ethan no
i don't want any journeys
no [ __ ] journey you do like a pro
wrestling journey oh you wouldn't handle
that no no journeys
what part of no journeys didn't you
understand
because of him getting the knockout
jake paul
literally has blown up to as big as he
is because he's knocking people out left
and right like that's not true
hmm yeah one knockout recently yeah so
he's
oh no he knocked out bennett
right but again it's one of these things
where it's like
fought nissan gibb didn't knock him out
one uh
fought uh tyrone the first time didn't
knock him out yeah uh i think was a tire
and that was a way bigger match by the
way yeah nobody watched the second time
yeah and ian talked about that in his
video like the mystery is going away so
less people are like buying it out of
like curiosity so the pay-per-views are
like we think that's why they're going
down right makes sense well the second
yeah
the second fight doesn't surprise me at
all like nobody was [ __ ] care about
that it really depends on who he's
fighting in my opinion like i was
curious to see him fight yeah that one
dude we bought tickets because we
thought he was fighting fury oh right
yeah that would have been a good fight
the guy's actually a boxer
yeah it was weird how it just got
canceled at the last minute his broken
ribs he broke his ribs uh in sparring
that's the problem with like uh and we
worry about it with our fighters um you
know they're sparring they can get
injured at any yeah they're doing
everything physical like yeah you need
to keep up the intensity yeah you know
every day so get sick
yeah you know
yeah we were really paranoid about that
of it as well
just general sickness it's like yeah
well if you're in florida they don't
even think it exists there yeah that's
true
we just got our uh
our booster and our flu shot combined we
did that's good but it hit it hit me
like a
truck what you had covered recently no
it's just like oh the shot shot itself
yeah yeah
but all right let's get through this
[ __ ] maniac i don't understand what's
wrong with that
you know if you get the knockout that's
the best thing you can hope for right
um he's about to cry though what was the
other point you made i don't i don't
even know look you're trying to do
something completely different all right
um and i wish you the best of luck and i
hope your event is wildly successful i
want more people involved in influencer
boxing um and i'm interested to see how
this pans out for you but
i mean
how are you against trash talk when you
just uploaded a video trash talking me
such a dumb ass point like you weren't
trash talking to him you were
you were
bringing up yeah you were countering
influencer boxing right like your trash
talk would be like saying that you're
like you know
kind of a parentless gnome or stuff like
that yeah i'm ugly ugly
unlovable like i trash.com you didn't
see anything like that
no no i definitely didn't like saying
keemstar stays the same or keemstar gets
older but his girlfriends stay the same
age that's trash talk where's that from
that's from uh fast times i think oh
dave isn't confused are dazed and
confused yeah you know that's trash shot
do you guys want a coffee drink i'll
take a coffee drink coffee yeah coffee
drink oh okay
i wasn't sure
promoting your event by talking [ __ ]
about everyone else's event like you're
literally doing what i've been telling
you to do talk [ __ ]
all right
yeah but anyway that's him
nice
what i love about that is a lot of that
footage of him that you use in your
video ian is he was talking he was
talking to hundar to knock me out like
that whole knockout rant was about me
and i think he was just trying to like
bait me or piss me off or scare me and
not realizing that he's exposing that he
doesn't know [ __ ] about boxing while
he's saying that exactly well also he's
gone out of his way in spite of me to
never mention a b um oh [ __ ] let's go oh
yeah that works oh yeah yeah we've got a
whole delivery starbucks
what is this one i'll take whatever i
don't well thank you
thanks
okay awesome thank you what is that one
it is creamy cold brew you want this one
or you want that one i want this one
okay
no i don't care
all right well anyway um
oh yeah and he was also asked he was
also saying the same thing to dad he was
saying so are you gonna go for the
knockout it's like a just a strategy
question it's just it's like a dumb
question right because it's like i'm
just fighting yeah and the plan changes
also depending on where you're at yeah
maybe you get in there you're [ __ ]
[ __ ] rock like
then you're you're you're just in there
to survive and oh what about your phone
that thing's like carbonated
no i faked it but
too much just like things like this you
need to shake yeah they're like the
canned i guess you shake did you shake
yourself i don't think i did no
um and then also just in keemstar
fashion he went after your significant
other which is kind of his go-to
uh he said i liked ian's response by the
way though you you get the the mountain
cersei in the mountain so let's see
because he's saying that he's going to
have some of his happy punch people
spar me represent him right he's cersei
yeah right cersei in the mountain you
scroll down it says strength wait click
on the image itself oh you can't oh damn
that off dang it it said what does it
say it just is like strength it's like a
it's like a tarot card deviantart got it
but then of course he uh
he's attacking anissa which is what he
does he calls i've been with a fight
yeah i've been witchified yeah
welcome to the yeah basically he's
calling you away yeah because she is
she's the red witch yep and how dumb of
you for thinking that that's what he's
saying well it's true i know i wasn't
location designated you just said that
about yourself
[ __ ] just that's a picture yeah just
doesn't mean yourself you said you're a
witch i told on myself i it's true i
have special spells so wait i thought he
was already using the witch on lena like
he doesn't have anything
all women are witches new content well
anyway he really hates crazy he really
hates women um he calls uh lena evie's
wife a witch he calls him don't worry we
hate him too
yeah yeah exactly
to be honest i was genuinely kind of
disappointed in that because i i hate
that narrative i mean it's probably no
secret that i hate that narrative uh but
it i wanna i've been with him for
two content cops through two content
cops and i helped like i mean
i yeah a lot of people's um
uh
i guess criticism is like oh like
that witch or that yeah
um well changed him or a lot of people
have they've gotten bad since they've
gone together type thing a lot of people
attack anissa people are like obsessed
with well they just don't understand
that she's been like helping me create
videos since
we got together and a lot of the things
that a lot of the videos that people
love
um
are with her help and involvement and
it's been the same thing all the way the
rice gum won i remember you were there
yeah you had a lot you were at a lot of
input on that one yeah the rice gum one
was a lot of fun i really like but i
mean
uh i also take ownership for the tana
the the tana thing was uh was mine that
was so long ago it was my idea it was my
stupid idea i was the one who suggested
like we can go to the
place it's just in san francisco i'm
like it is just in san francisco yeah
that drive and everything and now i
think back to it i'm like i can't
believe we literally harassed an 18 year
old child uh at her show it's like kind
of that's a i guess when you put it that
way
yeah it's horrendous it's probably like
my most like it is it's [ __ ]
embarrassing but i mean it was things
that a lot of people loved i mean yeah i
mean it was it was like uh i can
recognize why it was entertaining i
could also recognize why it was
completely out of line yeah
i she could have owned us
honestly yeah if she just acted mature
yeah if she would have to right it was a
risky move but but she really
couldn't it's gonna turn out better for
you guys how that went you couldn't
believe that she made a video afterward
and she didn't know that it was i'll
tell you
she had no idea she just thought it was
like a crazy fan it was crazy when we
were in the car so we like drove we
stayed with a friend and we were driving
back we did like the seven eight hour
drive and in the car after everything
had transpired
ian's sitting there and i'm sitting
there and i looked at him and i was like
i don't think she knew that was you she
described you as a psycho fan in her
video yeah she didn't know awesome she
and i mean that played perfectly into
your video i i think i don't know i was
what we did like so do an impulse buy of
our merch while we were there we did
yeah and we loaded up on the merch like
in the line right i remember that yeah
yeah i mean it's like oh my goodness
yeah it's part of like the history of
like the channel and stuff but
definitely like look i mean as almost 30
year olds or he is 30 it's like you look
back on that and you're like holy [ __ ] i
can't believe we [ __ ] it was a
different time back then for sure i
don't think it's fair to say it was that
different it was just uh i think i was
different for sure well that's i think
people have the same problem with me
mm-hmm this is the same i've roamed with
you is that we both used to be like edgy
comedians and we were a part of the
larger commentary community
and as we've aged we've realized that uh
you know you want to conduct yourself
differently well when you start starting
with the actual world and you're not in
your bedroom creating like a
like sitting in your bedroom for 19
hours creating a hit piece on someone
basically like and you actually interact
with human beings you sort of realize
like that isn't really real life
also i think like to be fair like the
only fan stuff like really was a huge
wake-up call
to both of us like emotionally what
happens when like the internet kind of
collectively shits on you so by the way
people don't know so you guys started
dating you decided to
make an only fans but that was like
years after you guys were already
together yeah we were together for four
years pretty much at that point and so
then when you made that only fans there
was like a huge
a lot of people cared which was very
surprising i don't i think yeah so what
happened i mean in your in your
perspective
from my perspective it was basically
like i think i had given off this uh
uh persona of like not
liking promiscuous women or like
thoughts e-girls [ __ ] whatever you want
to say
i think people like saw my video with
tana
you know with anna about tana and
thought like oh yeah like
he doesn't like people like this and we
will collectively like laugh and point
at and make fun of and to clarify people
like this meaning like
women who are not
like the modest wojack meme i mean women
a modern woman who is who is
has control of herself yeah exactly so a
lot of times what they do to me is that
they would put their values onto me and
be like he's just like me and then when
they find out you're not just like them
then they [ __ ]
i was just gonna add you were also very
like the the untouchable
idubbbz that like people
you never given them anything you're
always very careful
and you knew how to conduct yourself and
you were putting these videos that like
like you said looking back at it it's
kind of like a hit piece
but you didn't give them any info about
yourself and like
you wouldn't mess up like you knew
right and i didn't live stream and i you
know i didn't do any of that for a
reason right didn't give and i think a
lot of like the commentary community has
kind of woken up to that idea you'll see
a lot of them shifting from like
uh doing essentially hit pieces on
people to like i'm going to review a
movie now or i'm going to review tv
shows things that are like a lot more
mm-hmm appropriate yeah and uh not
psychotic yeah i mean there's plenty of
psychotic ones oh sure yeah they're not
as popular no
yeah and so it's it's just it's it's
like they were waiting for something
definitely and then that was that
opportunity all of a sudden the
opportunity what was the joke that like
uh
uh that uh you're a [ __ ] or something
yeah yeah yeah
yeah all right
that was a lot it was a big shock though
because but not like in a funny way like
in a really
like misogynistic gross like
bizarro worldwide i think the most
disappointing thing to me is how many
youtubers that i
respected uh had this weird view that
ian wasn't comfortable like just assumed
that ian wasn't comfortable with what
was going on literally our whole
relationship has been like
just mutual respect and understanding
everything we've ever done whether it's
him or me it's been like heavily talked
about
um like decisions together
uh including this and it was like it
wasn't exciting like we were both like
this is such a cool like oh how smart
what are like a what an easy way to make
some extra money yeah and it's and
you're dead
i mean
as an instagram yeah just a bit more
lewd yeah and the plan wasn't even to be
like yeah in the first place yeah it was
just to be like it was full it was just
like
lingerie uh at the beginning and i make
crazy money off of like lingerie i mean
i could i could have posted a lot of
that on instagram like 99 of it but like
people were really it was like
it was just weird some people got like
uh
i don't know like some people were like
defending by saying she's not actually
doing uh full nudity or whatever but
like in my video because it's
appropriate to take the stance
like you're either okay with sex work or
you aren't like this in between is like
not you're like it doesn't matter if
it's lingerie or right and i was and i
think i made comments in my video at the
time of like yeah my girlfriend can show
her you know whatever she wants on the
internet like i don't give a [ __ ]
and uh i think people took that and they
assumed like oh you're going full bore
their imaginations start to run wild
because i think the amount of porn they
watch and then it just goes you know to
the furthest darkest depths of the
internet it was real interesting to see
the reaction because you think like that
we're more evolved yeah and then you
realize like
i don't know if it's just these internet
kids and all but like the reaction was
it was insane it was shocking it was
shocking i i won't lie like at that
point in my life like my dad's
alzheimer's had just gotten like he had
like
reached the point of like no return and
then this internet stuff was happening
and like there were some days where like
literally like couldn't get out of bed
because it was just so
aggressive and it was like youtubers
that i never thought would even know
that i existed were talking about
ian's opinion about me when they have no
clue
so it was like it was super
strange but it was also really
eye-opening to us to like understand
what
that effect is and like what we were
doing to people so you s so you were
very successful in the only fans and
then you recently or somewhat recently
stopped yeah i was slowing down just
because like
for the past year this boxing stuff has
been like i mean we can't do anything
are you active now um like i am active
like i you know i'm on there but i'm not
like taking photos and i mean this is
the first time i've worn makeup and like
i mean i can't even do my makeup most
days because we're like training and
doing oh so it's just not your focus it
just can't you know i i'll probably see
every time we do a boxing session like
she comes with me every time does almost
the exact same work except for the
sparring so yeah we're yeah doing
everything together so well i guess and
keemstar was pretty
focal in this whole
attack on you of him and a lot of people
he's associated with right so what he's
doing is basically hitting hue where he
knows that it's painful yeah that i've
ruined his life you're basically
the red witch who was [ __ ]
enchanted uh bewitched stannis and
well he's saying you have no agency
yeah and he's saying that you're a witch
yeah yeah and that ian would burn his
child yeah so deep and well thought out
from the man from buffalo
it was i it was though genuinely
shocking because it is like my biggest i
mean there's like some days where i ask
you and like have i ruined your life
like i feel like something because you
get so many messages yeah where like you
have to think about it it's like
i mean i showed up you know 2016 and now
here we are and ian is doing different
stuff like ian as a person has not
changed
very much in like regards to his like
moral stance on a lot of things but like
ian and how he feels about how he wants
to put himself on the internet has
changed but i think that was going to
happen no matter what that's what he
always says that had to happen yeah
those videos like you said now they were
a hate piece and when you look back at
it you cringe
absolutely it's not something that could
have been sustainable even if you wanted
to look if you didn't change you
couldn't you'd just be you'd be keemstar
right yeah and also yeah yeah youtube
changed as a platform they don't allow
stuff like that anymore like they did
back then everything changes yeah and
like so you shouldn't feel like yeah
you're good you changed yeah yeah yeah i
think well i'm sure you know that but
yeah i guess you have insecurity about
it because yeah keemstar and people like
him
yeah it's hard he's a he sucks he's a
piece of [ __ ]
so they [ __ ] hate that guy maybe it's
just like a lebanese girl thing because
anissa and lena are both lebanese maybe
it's uh
yeah so it's like a racist i think i
think it's like
the nose it's the lebanese yeah i'm
telling you yeah there's something about
it that also seems come on
don't even say that you have a perfect
name i got i did like i have like a
little bit but it's very small
don't even say keemstar notices
[Laughter]
you know this is all imperfections
well there you go when you have a
perfect um by mind body and soul is him
then you have a team star if you're
listening to this
i know that you actually do mean well
yeah
uh and i do believe you when you say you
want the event to be a success
um i'm sorry if my words hurt your
feelings i
i was hurt by your words
which is why i retaliated the way that i
did and he said what that hurt you
uh just that we're running the event
poorly and that's pretty much it yeah
which was enough it's hard we care about
this [ __ ] yeah you work hard some
[ __ ] game stars don't you i mean your
whole life is about it's our baby
literally like it's kind of crazy we
didn't like we didn't do a wedding other
than going to vegas we didn't plan
anything and then all of a sudden we
decided to host a giant
like influencer box this is your wedding
this is our wedding basically
so it's like we've we we're so
passionate about it
we're how do you guys do a wedding i
want to do like a sort of reception a
reception with everyone but
and you know my family can't quit at the
time there's not any sort of hurry yeah
yeah yeah it'll be fun but the vegas
[ __ ] was so fun it was cool we did a uh
elvis thing oh really yeah it was fun
yeah we had uh izzy uh twitch pink she's
a streamer she came she was our witness
it's very sweet it's cool that's fun
yeah
so
yeah i mean
man you're hearing that ian
yeah look at that hair bro you what are
you doing with your hair you're doing a
mullet thing yeah
do you like that the mullet thing is
coming back and i gotta say i just
not totally on board with them all
yeah
yeah i feel like with the mustache and
the american traditional but you like it
i i like it i think it works for you
yeah i agree it's it's not well the
mullet isn't that intense yet but are
you planning on how long are we going to
see how it goes
yeah i think with the features like the
sharp like you're sharp featured so the
mullet looks good i think if you're like
softer featured the mullet doesn't look
good all right he's a bad boy is he a
bad boy he looks evil kinda evil
our coach said that he looks evil and i
asked her coach i was like do i look
evil and he was like no i'm upset i
won't look evil i think you said that
like an evil guy yeah which i'm jealous
of i think that's cool but i have the
same problem as a b i've got the big big
eyes yeah so when i look i just look at
a scared little [ __ ] because imagine
he has small eyes but when i'm looking
down i look just scared my eyes are so
big
well
yeah it's the big brow too and then when
abe and um
ian sparred a b brought up a good point
that i even think about like ian's got
this brow that like
like if he's not going to get hit in the
eye and have his eyes like [ __ ] up the
brow scares like a b ave is going to get
his eye popped out like whatever
i think in two rounds it was one eye the
first round and then the other eye just
like that's never happened before but
you put your head down and look in the
camera look at his your eyes are
protected yeah literally they're
shielded yeah they're shooting like a
but then av do that av do that like he's
gonna get he's gonna get
he's gonna get punched in the eye
i of have like dough dough eyes yeah
you've got eye shields it's like you're
wearing a helmet um
yeah damn i will say your guys's eyes
are a lot more aesthetically pleasing
the lebanese eyes yes
my weakness
ian does like my eyes he says all the
time he likes my eyes my eyes are my
smile so he tells you wait so he
actually what else does he call you
he loves your eyes and your smile it's
true
what else does he say to you heard it
here first
he likes how uh outspoken
yeah oh yes
i think a lot of people like hear her
talk and they're like oh what the hell i
wouldn't like that
and they want like a wife or a partner
who's like quiet and
yeah and i'm like yeah i i don't really
care about that
yeah i never should what do you love
about him i love that he thinks really
hard about what he says and he always
like has the perfect thing to say he's
just so smart and he's thoughtful
and when he says something he says
something when it means something
interesting
what else
i like
okay okay
we're good
he gets shot one more thing
i like his i i like his brow and also we
love his nose i just i think he's hot
his face
he's hot yeah [ __ ] yeah that sounds good
all right this is cool that's awesome
yeah that sounds good to me he gets shot
he is i i actually
uh gas him up a lot i'll tell him that
he looks hot or handsome or he's got big
ham cheeks and he gets mad what his ass
yeah you got a fatty
he's got a huge dump truck
not in the same way sweet
he tweeted out his his you can see his
whole backside on twitter
oh yeah i did see it yeah i was
impressed yeah
i took that picture that was me i was
gassing him up yeah you're in the you
need to be doing like
he's got back dimples oh wait only wait
i literally just went to my mentions and
this was
this was what popped up
i just tweeted out yeah we did see that
that you posted you are totally hairless
dude damn yeah
my ass does not look like in fairness
that was some
uh editing on a niece's party i did it
you edited his app
what did you edit i'd have someone
comment in the replies like uh some [ __ ]
about how like ian's editing is so much
better than like anises or whatever it's
just like he's going to [ __ ] edit it
oh my god you can't even wait what did
you edit his ass to make made it look
nice i smoothed it you smoothed it
working on like skin work so it looks
like real skin what the [ __ ] where's my
ass yeah did you smooth your eyes
transparency
my ass looks horrible dude
yeah
i i did a lot of favors for him i also
just worked on some shadow work and like
tried to make i am bro yeah i've learned
some skills over the
years the only fan's years
yes a fight his ass yeah yeah i did i
did yesterday although somebody did go
in there and really gassify your ass and
it looked
amazing yeah it will did that very slump
um
i guess that's about it for us we gotta
head home we have a it's passover today
actually congratulations
[Laughter]
well passover's about the jews escaping
slavery right
so congratulations is in order
we're
no longer being slaves
so thank you for that thank you very
much
so you guys are in la for a little bit
longer are you going back soon um uh
yeah we'll we'll uh go to las vegas uh
after this
and yeah i guess final plugs is uh we're
going to do the open workout with ab and
company tomorrow on s fans channel noon
so look out for that they can come or
just watch the twitch just watch the
trick yeah don't go oh oh okay
okay and uh in-person tickets are going
fast if you if this event sounds
interesting
is there like a is there a seating chart
if i go to the website yeah yeah i want
to see that yeah creator club clash
creator
the link is in the description by the
way
so the creator clash it's in florida
yeah you can go down the bottom
keep going
right there take it to event
guys how is it possible that
oh i remember you guys said limited
quantity to the stream tickets
i was like what for early bird oh for
right right for the earliest price got
it
um all right so what does this mean all
the gray is taken it's sold out oh good
seeds um yeah the lighter blue
is available
yeah so those are two thousand dollars
and boy let's
go this whole section
why would people buy
middle is a thousand and then front rows
two thousand
um the whole lower bowl within i'm not
even kidding five minutes ten minutes of
it launching was gone wow which is the
lower bowl like all that gray stuff yeah
the hundreds there's 100 bucks yeah yeah
that's a lot of seeds how many seeds
have you guys sold already uh 5 000. no
way that's great well how big is this
it's a 10 000 seed arena technically
closer to 9 000 i think nine thousand
once we uh get everything so how much is
the how much are these uh uh the ones at
the top top end are like 25 i think okay
um
but i will say we went to the arena
ourselves a couple days ago and uh it's
not a big arena as far as like you're
not far from the action right it kind of
looks that way in these pictures but
it's just like it's very intimate very
close like even the high up seats
available
and i kind of wish i could go but i
don't know what week is it on the
weekend
it'll be on a saturday yeah
the we'll have a lounge for it's just
influencers to chill in
we
oh my god oh that's exciting sounds like
it's doing great already five thousand
sold that's awesome yeah we were shocked
by that's great the support i mean like
we were super nervous about it but yeah
maybe we should try yeah it's just i
mean like i have no idea right now
but we have to figure it out because we
have like a wedding that we need to go
to
but it's now it's like two kids and two
dogs yes i have no idea how yeah we can
throw these dogs in a freaking kennel no
no
we'll never you won't leave the house no
there's that there are like four hours
day care waiting day care is amazing
listen nothing against daycare and
kennels i think it's totally fine
i
have
we just try to go out to have a nice day
out yeah with our kid right and he's
worried about the dogs and they're home
no people because i know how stressful
it is for them but there are there are
dog sitters who do a great job of like
updating i get pictures
every
we're playing ball we're having a good
time they just sit by the door and cry
they do
but they do that even if i'm home you
know it's like what can you do that's
fine
maybe we can bring them
that's definitely not you you've got
you've got to get to the point where you
could where you're able to leave because
that's i think he has a bigger anxiety
separation anxiety from them well
they're happy with my parents that's
always good they are yeah they don't
mind being with them but you don't want
to have to rely on two kids
they're forgot their own [ __ ] they want
to do right no
no but they they have to watch the kids
if we go yeah
that's a problem
kids and two dogs i don't know dogs love
like would you leave your kid with some
weird [ __ ]
playground lady i mean
like to be fair it's not just absolutely
i know
it's kind of like you you're going to
have to put your kids in school as well
and they're going to be a stranger
they're in school are theodores in
school essentially a stranger that
watches over them and you're not like oh
these weirdos don't have these weirdos
looking after our boston terrier has
intense separation issues and he's
really learned to love he loves that
place he loves it he gets so excited
there are some really nice ones a good
place like how do you feel so the
biggest thing to do is you ask them to
like tour the facility if they're not
open to letting you tour then like oh
hell no and then the other thing is like
ask them like
how honest are you and how open are you
with like what happens here like if it's
a daycare that like if a bite happens or
if like two dogs get into it and they
don't want to tell you about it if like
nothing happened you don't want to take
them there but why would they tell you
the truth if they're liars
well i mean you want to hear somebody
like because some of them will say like
oh you know like yeah we'll we'll tell
you how it goes and then you do a trial
and you hear nothing and then it's kind
of like but again it's all different
it's like you can like depending on your
level of dedication is searching you can
find places where it's just like only
the small dogs interact with each other
watching small dogs there's some places
where it's like a person in their living
room so it's no different than you at
your home and you just have you know
they they only take five dogs at a time
or something rover has good ratings
that's puppy prison
puppy prison it's puppy prison what kind
of crack are you smoking
yeah and they're loving live they're
loving that more than they like the dog
sitters more than they like us because
they're engaged with them the whole day
and they have friends we just sit on the
couch and watch like shocks and 90 day
fiance and these dogs are just suffering
on the floor yeah the day cares actually
play with them and [ __ ] yeah we consider
it their vacation when we leave because
they're like more fun
and there's nothing wrong with that i
wish you i would have no you got it but
you're living we're gonna have you board
them
i mean we're hearing this it sounds
really nice yeah i'd be open to trying
some places yeah also dogs like
it's it's a it's a little bit of a tough
transition to get a dog to sleep in like
a kennel if you don't kennel them
that is super comforting for a dog once
they understand that that's a safe place
for them to be often times like dogs who
you know grow up in that they just want
to go into the kennel for like reprieve
yeah fiona like we took away her kennel
because it's like it takes some space
and she just like goes under our bed now
shredder used to do that yeah yeah our
bed is too low but you used to sleep
under our bed sometimes and they're only
in there when you know they need to uh
whether they're i guess being fed or
when they need to go to sleep every
other hour of the day they're out
honestly
honestly
it sounds like the green mile to me
i don't get that reference what does
that mean
the kennel they got all the cages
they're all on death row
nah walking the green mile they i the
kennel really helped blitz with his
insecurity too i it can be an electric
chair there
it can be a great tool if you know if
you're not abusing it right because like
people will abuse the kennel like
they'll just shove their dog in there oh
gosh but like if you're using it as in
like
especially what kind of people yeah
bad people some people really don't
[ __ ] care about their dogs
legit it happens some people like put
their dog in like their laundry room and
kind of just i mean there's
so upsetting um but especially when
they're puppies like kind of like kids
putting down your kid for a nap because
your kids are overtired and they don't
know it puppies do that too and the
kennel is a great way to like shut their
brain off kind of like putting them to
sleep it's routine it's routine putting
them to sleep
bro i knew i didn't like these places
hell nah
well no it is it is good you're supposed
to like every hour let your puppy have a
nap and then you bring it to take them
out and play with them yo we've been
going three and a half hours all right
we gotta wrap this up oh wow oh my god
well we talked a lot about boxing yeah
super excited about the event the
creator clash.com
a b is gonna be there
maybe we'll try to figure out how to go
but if not we'll regardless what we're
going to cover it we'll talk about it
i'm so excited to watch it even if it's
just through this ram but well i'm very
excited for exciting i'm glad that
you're doing it like the legit way it
sounds really cool excited for you for a
b and dad who's going to crush that drug
addict freak matt or whatever his name
is
and eric
oh and eric right eric eric's fighting
my boy oh yeah
he's not gonna last long but it's going
to be fun very confident
it's going to take a cigarette break
he's going to exactly
yeah true but we love him for that bless
him yeah we love him
all right thanks for coming guys thank
you hope everyone had a good time it's
friday baby
uh
horsecock energy
yeah baby
baby
um i guess that's about it so uh thanks
for watching yada yada yada thank you to
coach
yeah thank you michael briggs bonafide
boxing boxing
michael briggs bonafide boxing
you heard it here he says he could beat
up any of the other coaches easy
yeah
that's true mad fact no cap
no capping allowed my coaching to beat
me up for not defending him av do you
want to say anything before we sign off
i know thank you to all the support you
don't want to you don't want to defend
your coach what's up you don't want to
defend your coach
nah [ __ ] that guy no no i love my coach
but he's not going to watch this okay
and he's been yelling either way so
go ahead what were you going to say
thank you say thank you to everyone
showing sport it's really cool to see
everyone saying that they bought tickets
to come see me so i really do appreciate
it yeah
dumb [ __ ]
oh well keemstar is not happy about it
he's not happy about much thank you guys
be on monday have a good weekend
everybody have a good weekend later
later
you're watching h two three three three
three you're watching h two three three
three three you're watching h to the
three three three
[Music]